Ach ja, so Leute, da bin ich, ist so früh, aber ich bin schon ungefähr eine Stunde auf, aber ich bin nicht wach, oder sag mal, wach ist was anderes, sagt mal, hat irgendjemand diesen Overwatch 2 Reveal Stream gesehen, der vor ein paar Tagen war, das war ja nicht Stream, ja doch, war mal ein Stream, ich hab das als Wort geguckt, das war wieder sehr viel Gequatsche um nix,
es wirkte fast so, als kämpft die Marketingabteilung mit dem Entwicklungsteam, was denn jetzt eigentlich da gemacht werden soll, wann ist eigentlich Release Date, also aktuell schockt es mich, okay, Oktober, aktuell schockt es mich so überhaupt nicht, ich weiß nicht, es ist ja auch, es hat sich auch nix von dem verändert, was mich genervt hat, und ich glaube nicht, dass Blizzard an den eigentlichen Problemen dieses Game hat,
also vor allem der Support.
Wie es jahrelang jetzt gelaufen ist, dass sich da großartig was dran ändert, nicht so viele Hoffnungen drin, moin Leute, also, ich weiß nicht, wie lange ich jetzt on bin, ich bin übelst im Arsch noch, kann euch gar nicht so genau sagen, warum, aber irgendwie bin ich im Arsch, ich muss, ich muss, äh, am, äh, am Dienstag, wisst ihr, was ich da tolles machen muss auf der Arbeit,
Real Race.
Basil Chief, dankwürde, dáp.
Wisst ihr, was ich da, wisst ihr, was ich da Tolles machen muss?
Ich muss mit einem, ähm,
Techniker aus den USA
auf irgendeiner
Cloud Linux
VM
mit dem zusammen was, ähm,
installieren. Bin ich mal
gespannt, was da rauskommt.
Irgendwas, was ich noch nie im Leben installiert hab,
der soll mir irgendwie sagen, was ich machen muss.
Das hab ich mir auch gedacht,
ich hab mir auch schon gedacht, warum geben wir dem
nicht einfach remote zugreifen, das kann er selbst machen.
Aber man weiß ja nie.
Tja.
Gab es sonst was Spannendes die letzten
Tage über? Ich habe eine
China-Chinesen
Sponsoring-Anfrage bekommen.
Das muss ich euch mal vorlesen.
Da keckt er. Da keckt
ihr euch weg.
Keck-double-yut ihr euch weg.
Die fängt schon an mit,
die fängt schon an, also mit irgendeiner
keine Ahnung
China-Chinesen-Zeichen-E-Mail
und es fängt an
Hello my old friend.
My dear.
Das ist irgendein China-Chinesen-Text
übersetzt ins Englische.
Hello my friend, my dear.
So fangen natürlich alle Sponsoring-Anfragen
immer an.
Und was wollen sie mir
aufschwätzen?
Sie wollen
mir ein
ultra-holdable und
comfortable
48-Megapixel-Main-Kamera.
Was wollen die mir überhaupt aufschwätzen?
Ein Smartphone?
Ich glaube, die wollen mir ein Smartphone aufschwätzen.
Keine Ahnung.
Oh man.
Free-Crap braucht auch keiner.
Müll kriegt man überhaupt nicht.
Aber was Gescheites.
Die wollen dann ja auch was dafür haben.
Und das sehe ich nicht ein.
Ich bewerbe so ein Crap nicht.
Ich mache eh relativ wenig Sell-Outs.
Ich mache eigentlich nie großartig Sell-Outs.
Ich habe die letzten Jahre,
was habe ich gemacht?
Hetzner habe ich gemacht.
Das würde ich auch weitermachen,
weil ich den Kram eh benutze.
Und das auch ohne Sponsoring teilweise schon
hier im Stream gezeigt habe.
Ja, dann habe ich dieses Battlefield-Sponsoring gemacht,
wo man gemerkt hat,
dass ich keinen Bock mehr auf die Sponsorings hatte
nach zwei Videos.
Aber ich habe mir den halt drei Videos ausgemacht.
Ja gut, was willst du machen?
Ansonsten.
Ich glaube, irgendeinen Sniper-Elite-Sponsoring
habe ich mal gemacht die letzten Jahre über.
Nee, Raid.
Die sind bei mir auch laufend am Start.
Und VPN-Anbieter sind auch laufend am Start.
Und wisst ihr, was lustig ist?
Ich habe das ja schon erzählt.
Die waren doch neulich sogar im Chat.
Echt jetzt?
Im Stream?
Wirklich? Habe ich keiner mitbekommen?
Oder vor oder nach dem Stream?
Naja.
Was gibt es eigentlich?
Gibt es eigentlich einen einfachen Weg?
Was? Wo ist die Frage?
Gibt es...
Gibt es eigentlich auch einen einfachen Weg?
Ein C++? Ja, klar.
Es ist jetzt egal,
ob es GCC ist
oder
LLVM
C-Lang, wie auch immer man das ausspricht.
Ja, kannst du alles installieren.
Aber was ich gerne mache,
ist, ich verwende für diesen Krempel
ein Pack.
Ja, super.
Passive Message-Größe.
Ich verwende einen Package-Manager für Windows.
Ja, da ist alles mögliche drin.
Search, GCC.
Ich muss mal updaten wieder.
Ich meine, es ist Windows,
deswegen ist es nicht schnell.
Aber ansonsten, ich meine,
gibt es bestimmt
komplett fertige
C++-Entwicklungs-Bundles
für Windows.
Ach so, wenn du den
Microsoft-Krempel verwenden willst,
dann kannst du auch einfach
Visual Studio... Das stimmt, da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht.
Ja, klar. Du kannst auch den Visual Studio-Kram installieren
mit dem ganzen Microsoft-Krempel. Das geht auch.
Wahrscheinlich unter Windows sogar die beste Variante.
Äh, RealRenux?
Doch, hatte ich.
Aber
das ist nichts geworden.
Die haben sich das anders überlegt. Also, nee.
Die haben sich nicht anders überlegt. Die haben gesagt, der Termin ändert sich.
Und dann habe ich gesagt,
nee, zu dem neuen Termin passt das bei mir nicht.
Und seitdem habe ich nie wieder
was gehört.
Nee.
Nee, nee, also
Visual Studio ist die
Community Edition
ist free.
Welchen Package-Manager? Ich verwende Scoop.
Den da.
Ähm, es gibt dann auch noch
äh, es gibt dann auch noch den da.
Weiß gar nicht, ob ich das installiert habe. Nee.
Also der Unterschied ist,
Scoop installiert rein lokal ins
Heimatverzeichnis. Für andere
System-Wide. Ich finde das mit
ins Heimatverzeichnis besser.
Ja, du kannst ohne...
Ach, WinGet.
Absoluter Crap, man.
Also ich meine, mittlerweile ist es
benutzbar.
Mittlerweile ist es benutzbar.
Warte mal gucken, was auf GitHub da abgeht.
Mittlerweile ist es benutzbar, weil sie den Kram
wenigstens so eingerichtet haben, dass du mittlerweile
Software deinstallieren kannst.
Aber ganz ehrlich, das...
Also ich bin nicht sonderlich begeistert
von WinGet.
Ich müsste mir das einfach mal wieder angucken.
Ich müsste... Also das letzte Mal,
wo ich es mir angeguckt habe, ging das
Deinstallieren von Software noch nicht mal.
Mittlerweile geht das aber.
Was ich an Scoop mag, ist, dass es
ähnlich ist zu, äh,
Pac-Man oder UpGet
oder sonst was.
Ich müsste mir den Kram mal wieder
angucken, ob das mittlerweile taugt.
Ich bin mir halt nicht sicher, ob es dort
überhaupt genug Packages gibt. Also...
Sprich, welche
Sources verwendet das Ding?
Müssten wir mal ausprobieren.
Ah, okay.
Das letzte Mal hat mich WinGet
komplett kalt gelassen.
Könnte man vielleicht zu einem Stream angucken.
Aber dafür einen extra Stream machen ist, glaube ich,
unsinnig. Das dauert eine halbe Stunde, sich das anzugucken
mit allem Drum und Dran und dann ist gut.
Frage an den Chat.
Guckt ihr mal zufällig
die Orville Season 3?
Ich fand ja Season 1 wirklich richtig gut.
Also Massive Pog.
Season 2 fand ich
zum größten Teil auch ziemlich gut.
Aber die ersten drei Folgen von Season 3
finde ich auch wieder richtig gut.
Also...
Bessere Star Trek als
Star Trek, Alter.
Also gefällt mir echt gut.
Und ich feiere
wenige Serien so richtig.
Ja, gibt es aktuell nur auf Englisch.
Kann man aber schon beispielsweise über Amazon
oder irgendwelche anderen Streamen.
Original sind die jetzt irgendwie auf Disney Plus
oder auf Hulu oder was auch immer.
WTF.
Wusste ich bis dahin noch nicht mal,
dass es das überhaupt gibt.
Aber man kann es sich auf Amazon angucken.
Ich meine, bezahle ich halt 2 Euro pro Folge
oder so.
Was mir halt ein bisschen auf den Keks geht,
ist, dass die Folgen halt wieder einmal
also jeden Freitag die Woche
rauskommen und nicht einfach am Stück.
Aber ja, so ist das halt.
Manche stehen halt so auf das Serienfeeling.
The Boys habe ich aufgehört zu gucken
nach Anfang Staffel 2.
Also Staffel 1 fand ich zum größten Teil
ziemlich nice.
Vom Ende her war es ein bisschen langweilig.
Der Rest, also Staffel 2
hat mir dann schon gar nicht mal großartig gefallen.
Aber wie gesagt,
ich bin da eh, also
es gibt viele Serien, die ich gut fand.
1, 2 Staffeln
und dann
kam irgendwas, was mir nicht mehr gefallen hat.
Hör ich auf.
Zu gucken.
Also ich glaube, ich habe ganz, ganz wenige Sachen
wirklich komplett geguckt.
Ach ja, so.
Gibt es sonst noch irgendwas Spannendes?
Was können wir uns denn angucken?
Was gibt es denn? Was haben wir denn?
Was haben wir denn heute Spannendes?
Hat sich ein Jahr warten auf das Steam Deck gelohnt?
Eher nicht.
Which Battlefield Games are dead?
Also wirklich dead?
Komplett ohne Spieler?
Dürfte wahrscheinlich nur die ganz
alten sein, ja.
So Vietnam und
sonst was. Selbst BC2
und so kannst du ab und zu noch ein bisschen
spielen. Aber sagen wir mal so,
wenn man dead sagt, weniger als 5
aktive Server oder so, dann sind das ganz schön viele.
Expanse habe ich auch geguckt, Staffel
1 bis 1,5.
Wo sind die Entwickler hin?
Sind die immer noch da?
Battlefield 2042
Geheimnis aufgeklärt.
Krasses Geheimnis.
Was war das gerade?
Leute, ich habe da beim Refreshen, habt ihr das
auch gesehen? Ah, da ist es.
Wollte ich gerade sagen, ich habe noch irgendwelche
Kram gerade beim Screen Refresh gesehen.
Die meinen unbedingt,
dass wir das gucken sollen, aber ich will jetzt nicht
den Ventilator Teaser gucken. Das hört sich schon
ein bisschen
gänzwertig an.
Naja, so.
Das schauen wir uns an.
Es gibt nicht viel Gescheites.
Ne.
Und was? Was ich diese Woche gesehen habe?
Die Doku über die Cyberpolizistin wurde die Woche
über 10 Parts gespielt. Ja,
du meinst über die Cyberpolizistin, wo es
in dem ganzen Beitrag vielleicht eine Minute ums
Cyber ging?
Ne. Neues Video zur
E3.
Juckt mich so gar nicht, was auf der E3 passiert ist.
War die überhaupt schon?
Ach ja, das war das, wo sie dieses,
klar, das war doch, wo sie dieses
Open World Sonic gezeigt haben, wo sich
alle weggekeckt haben.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Das sah richtig Fail aus.
Ach, das war Summerfest.
Ach, keine Ahnung. Juckt mich
nicht. Man hat seit Corona gesehen,
dass Messen eigentlich total overrated,
dated, she-baited sind. Die Gamescom
war noch nie sinnvoll.
Nicht für Spiele. Die Gamescom ist
vielleicht ein Event für viele, wo man
vor Ort sich mit Leuten trifft,
die man lange nicht gesehen hat, irgendwas zusammen machen.
Also, die Gamescom
ist für viele eher so ein Real-Life-Event,
weniger Gaming-Messe.
Weil spielen kannst du auf der Gamescom eh vergessen.
Das heißt, du willst 3 Stunden anstehen für irgendwas.
Und
selbst,
wenn man da im Vorfeld Termine
macht, und dass man dann auch
Sachen gezeigt bekommt, selbst dann ist es
nicht sonderlich
spannend oder
sinnvoll. Also, die Gamescom ist komplett
umsonst gewesen.
Nicht preislich, ja, also
komplett unsinnig gewesen.
Deswegen geh ich da auch schon seit Jahren nicht mehr hin.
Und ob die jemals wieder in der alten Form stattfinden wird,
keine Ahnung. Mal gucken,
wie es dieses Jahr wird.
Es soll ja dieses Jahr, genau, das hab ich auch.
Also, es soll ja dieses Jahr ganz normal stattfinden. Ich bin mal gespannt,
in welchem Umfang und wie das
wieder ist. Ob das dann wieder wie vor Corona ist,
oder nicht.
Naja, da sind sie aber selbst dran schuld, wenn sie so einen Müll vorstellen, oder?
Ich mein, dann muss man sich,
da muss man sich ja dann nicht
irgendwie den Leuten
überlassen, sich das zusammenzureimen,
sondern könnte einfach was ordentliches
zeigen. Oder man lässt's halt
bleiben und zeigt was ordentliches, weil man was ordentliches
zeigen kann. Ich muss
sagen, es waren die letzten Jahre so wenige
AAA-Spiele dabei,
auf die ich mich A
gefreut hab, und B,
als die dann rausgekommen sind, auch,
wirklich was getaugt haben. Also, das letzte
Negativbeispiel, was mir dazu
einfällt, ist einfach Battlefield 2042.
Da hab ich
mich nach dem,
äh, nachdem es so die ersten Sachen gab, hab ich mich
mega drauf gefreut, hab gesagt, endlich mal wieder was
modernes Battlefield-Technik.
Ich hab ja auch Videos zugemacht, endlich mal wieder was modernes.
Das sieht auch gut aus, was man gesehen
hat, ähm,
aber es wurde halt komplett
verschissen. Komplett.
Ich hab ja damals,
als sie den Trailer hatten,
hatte ich ja mit dem Lost,
ähm, da haben wir
zwei, drei Stunden uns drüber ausgelassen,
und haben das, haben das
besprochen, wir waren beide übelst gehypt
da drauf, und man muss sagen,
die einzige Abteilung, die wirklich einen richtig
guten Job gemacht hat, bei Battlefield
2042, ist
die Marketingabteilung. Die haben's
drauf gehabt, also zumindest am Anfang.
Mittlerweile ja auch nicht mehr, also,
was gibt's, da gibt's ja auch ein wenig
noch schönzureden, aber
alles, was danach, aber was ich witzig
fand,
wir haben's lustigerweise in dem Stream damals
sogar schon, damals sogar schon gesagt,
ne, so nach dem Motto, alter, alles
mega geil, sonst wie, kann sich aber am Ende trotzdem
wie kurze spielen, und wir hatten recht,
es spielt sich am Ende wie kurze.
Es geht wahrscheinlich, Waffen sind nicht mehr
in, weil Amis, die stehen da
immer noch drauf, äh, Waffen daheim
zu haben, aber in letzten Jahren hat man
gesehen, dass viel mehr Games
weggehen davon, realistische Waffen
im Spiel darzustellen, also,
ich red jetzt nicht von Schwertern und Äxten und sowas,
das letzte hast du auch gesehen,
dass wieder,
dass sie dann angefangen haben, jetzt in Battlefield
2042 die Waffen nachzubauen, aber
denen andere Namen zu geben und sowas.
Okay, wahrscheinlich ist es viel schneller, ja.
Icefreak, danke, danke für den Sub.
Ich brauch übrigens unbedingt
mal neue, echt,
tatsächlich? Ich hätt jetzt gedacht, das ist deutlich
weniger.
Tja, da nicht.
Ähm, ich brauch unbedingt wieder neue
Subscriber-Dinger. Ich mein, du
bekommst, glaub ich, den,
seit, nach nem Jahr bekommst du den goldenen
Keks mit, mit Halskette.
Habt ihr ne gute Idee, was man noch
machen kann? Ansonsten muss ich mal
in mich gehen. Man könnte,
man könnte den sicherlich noch, noch ausbauen.
Den, den
Goldkeks. Eine Knarre.
Näh. Ein Hut.
Ein Hut. Das, das Problem ist,
Hut kann man nicht machen. Also,
wisst ihr, dass das tatsächlich
ziemlich pfeifherdig ist,
solche Dinger zu designen, weil,
dem kannst du beispielsweise keinen Hut
aufsetzen, dem Keks. Warum?
Weil, wenn man einen Hut nimmt,
nein, ja,
wenn man einen Hut nimmt,
dieses Bild ist immer das gleiche Seitenverhältnis.
Und wenn man einen Hut nimmt,
dann nimmt das hier oben die Ecke weg
und der ganze Keks wird kleiner, weil das Seitenverhältnis
von dem Bild gleich bleibt
und du erkennst den Keks nicht mehr.
Also, du kannst eigentlich nur was machen, was du
an diesem Keks selbst machst. Du kannst nix
um diesen Keks machen. Deswegen gibt es ja auch
so Sachen wie Headset.
Weil das, weil das, äh, kacke aussieht
in klein. Ja, genau.
Also, es ist gar nicht so, gar nicht so
einfach, sowas zu designen.
Die Augenfarbe kann man zum Beispiel machen
oder Keksfarbe
oder was der um den Hals hat oder
vielleicht was er was in der Hand hat
oder vielleicht hier oben so ein
Stirnband, keine Ahnung,
irgendwie so, aber du kannst, ansonsten
kannst du nix machen. Das muss
Ghostface. Ja, das
könnte, so, so Dinger. Sonnenbrille,
ja, tatsächlich. Ja, ja.
Genau, genau. Das, das geht natürlich auch.
Sowas. Es ist tatsächlich nicht
so einfach.
Ja, der Mittag war's hoch. Ich hab jetzt
jemand, der
mir Stream
ähm
Highlights zusammenschneidet.
Richtig gut, finde ich. Manche,
also, es dürft, es haben ja schon ein paar Leute Probe
geguckt. Manche haben gesagt
Cringe Humor. Wobei ich's gar
nicht so schlimm finde. Ich find's passt eigentlich ziemlich gut.
Aber die meisten fanden's gut,
ich bin mal gespannt. Das ist nämlich
eine super Alternative, dass ich,
äh, weil ich bin jetzt ja nicht da grad die krasse
Content-Maschine, was YouTube-Videos angeht.
Ich mach alle, keine Ahnung, 14 Tage
ein Video oder so aktuell.
Oder wenn was ist. Und es
gibt doch im Stream ab und an
die ein oder anderen interessanten
Dinger, was wir uns mal angucken
und wo wir uns mal drüber auslassen. Und wenn das
jemand zusammenschneidet von meinem
45-Minuten-Stunden-Gelaber
zu, äh,
unter
10 Minuten ist das, find ich, recht unterhaltsam.
Das können wir uns ja
am Mittag angucken. Also, was heißt
wir? Wir nicht, also.
Ihr könnt euch das angucken, wenn ich's hochgeladen hab.
Die meisten Leute, die öfters im Stream dabei sind,
waren vielleicht sogar dabei, wo ich's erzählt hab.
Aber, ja, mal gucken.
Das ist ja kein Ersatz
für irgendwie Content. Ansonsten gäbe's
einfach kein Content, bis man wieder danach ist,
alle zwei bis drei Wochen
ein Video aufzunehmen. So gibt's vielleicht öfters
mal was. Und ich find das richtig gut geschnitten,
so. Also,
YouTube, letzte Chance.
Letzte Chance, empfehlt mir was Gescheites.
Solltest das.
So.
Das schrecklichste Release der PlayStation 3.
Ach so, die,
ja, gut. Also, eines der schlimmsten
Sachen,
was Konsolenankündigungen angeht,
fand ich immer noch die Xbox One.
Also, die Xbox One, das war so
How to verkacken
Any% Also, das war kompletter
Schwachsinn. Erinnert ihr euch noch?
Ähm, äh, erinnert ihr euch
noch dran, als die bei der
Xbox One Präsentation
ernsthaft irgendwelche Football Games
oder Basketball, ich glaub Football war's,
irgendwelche Football Games gezeigt
haben und dann erzählt haben,
wie geil das ist, dass man sich im Overlay einblenden
kann auf der Xbox One für die Football
für Football Games.
Und da haben halt alle sich gedacht,
ja, okay,
Kokona Stuff, wen juckt's?
TV, TV,
ja, genau.
Wo ich immer noch nicht gecheckt habe,
was zum Teufel haben die da
getrieben und sich gedacht,
was geht da?
Wie schnell das Geld mit Phishing weg ist.
Okay, da, der NDR Ratgeber
erklärt uns das.
Aber 17 Minuten, Alter.
Irgendwann.
So, da hinten so.
Ich mein, für irgendwas muss ich ja meine Gebühren bezahlen.
So viel kriegen YouTuber.
Ach, gibt's mal wieder hier. Ich habe alle Placements
angenommen. Das war gar nicht schlecht,
das Video des Letztes. Fand ich eigentlich ganz cool.
Cave Exploring
gone wrong. Alles klar.
Der Kerl ist immer noch am Tunnel graben.
Das haben wir doch vor einem Jahr zuletzt geguckt.
Wir haben nur vor einem Jahr oder so
mal ein Video von dem geguckt,
wo er angefangen hat, diesen Tunnel zu buddeln.
Okay, so ein Tunnel buddelt sich wahrscheinlich
nicht so easy einfach mal so.
Dauert wohl eine Weile.
Kauf zwei, dann hast du eine.
Wie, man muss zwei Packages kaufen,
dass man eine Pyramide bekommt? Wirklich?
Das ist ja massive
Geld machen.
Money
making
bei Nintendo.
Windows Defender now available for all platforms.
Das ist doch jetzt schon.
Okay, auf iOS.
Also, wir haben auf unseren Linux-Servern schon
lange
Microsoft Advanced Threat Protection.
Ich finde es
mega beschissen und ich habe das an einigen Stellen
auch schon gesagt, aber alle sagen sich,
ja, aber Security, das muss sein.
Wir brauchen Advanced Threat Protection.
Auf allen Linux-Systemen.
Das Ding, also wir hatten dadurch
noch keinen Vorteil, wir hatten bisher nur Nachteile.
Wusstet ihr eigentlich, dass
Microsoft die Advanced Threat Protection
live patchen kann?
Also damit hat
quasi Microsoft
ein Backdoor auf jedem
deiner Server.
Also der Windows Defender patcht
sich live angeblich irgendwelche
irgendwelche Updates.
Allerdings können die nicht nur Updates patchen,
sondern auch wirklich Funktionen am Defender.
Das heißt, sobald du Windows Advanced Threat Protection
auf deinem Linux-Server drauf hast,
hast du effektiv ein Microsoft Backdoor
auf deiner Kiste.
Wer diesen
Scheiß ernsthaft installiert
und wer im Management diesen Schwachsinn
entscheidet, das kann ich nicht nachvollziehen.
Passwörter mittig zu dem
Klartext speichert. Ja, das hatten wir
auch schon. Wie gesagt, ich habe schon
Passwörter im Klartext in irgendwelchen Defender-Logs
gefunden. Okay, komm, gucken wir gleich.
Erstmal den
Level Cap Gbait.
Leute, der
tägliche, jährliche, monatliche,
wöchentliche Level Cap
Gbait. Das muss sein.
Lass uns mal Level Cap Gbaiten.
Hast du das Drama um Googles AI
mitbekommen? Ne, was war?
Was war das Drama?
Was war das Drama um Googles AI?
Habe ich nicht mitbekommen.
Ich kann mich noch an das Drama
über Microsofts Nazi
AI erinnern.
Weiß das noch jemand?
Microsoft hat mal einen Twitter-Bot gemacht.
Was ist das denn hier?
Microsoft hat mal einen
Twitter-Bot rausgebracht,
der lernen sollte, wie man auf Twitter
eben mit Leuten kommuniziert.
J oder, genau, genau,
dieses Ding meine ich. Also Microsoft hat mal
einen Bot auf Twitter rausgebracht, der
aus Twitter lernen soll, wie man auf Twitter
kommuniziert. Das Problem war, dass der nach ein paar
Tagen nur noch Nazi-Kommentare
und rechtsextreme Sachen
gepostet hat.
Also,
da
denkt man sich auch, Alter,
das hätten die sich auch denken können,
weil ganz im Ernst,
dass die Leute, wenn die das mitbekommen,
nicht normal diesen Bot
antworten.
Mich würde es nicht wundern, wenn da
4chan wieder dran beteiligt war, im Zweifelsfall.
Hat Chatbot
Lambda ein Bewusstsein entwickelt?
Ok, lass mal abkürzen, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Google Urlaub Angestellten.
Weil bei Google niemand diese Überzeugung geteilt hat.
Ok, die haben,
Alter, die haben alle Dachschaden, Mann.
Was zum Teufel hat das denn jetzt mit
religiösen Überzeugungen zu tun?
Also sprich, er behauptet, nur, dass ich das mal richtig verstehe,
er behauptet, sein Chatbot
hätte, hätte,
quasi, wie sagt man,
Self-Awareness
so irgendwie entwickelt und bei Google
sagen alle anderen, die das sehen, nee, kann nicht
sein, du hast doch nicht mehr alle.
Und dann sagt er, ja, das macht nichts, ich muss
einfach nur dran glauben und hat sich jetzt darüber
beschwert, dass man ihn diskriminiert,
würde, weil,
hä?
Das ist auch wieder was, was
nur im Jahr 2022 passieren kann,
wahrscheinlich. Der Algorithmus würde
mitnehmen. Ok.
Stattdessen
hätten sie wiederholt seine Gesundheit in Frage
gestellt. Ja, kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass
da einige Dachschaden haben.
Also ich tendiere, ich tendiere
in dem Fall auch, ob ohne, ohne
diesen Chatbot zu kennen, ich tendiere auch
eher dazu, dass der Kerl
einen Dachschaden hat.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, was da noch rauskommt.
Mittlerweile sind Bots
eh schon an der, an der Grenze
dessen, wo man sich fragt, hm,
hat das nicht vielleicht
doch irgendein Mensch gemacht? Also auch die,
wie heißt diese, wie heißt diese
Übersetzungsseite?
War das DeepL? Ich weiß nicht.
Das ist auch ziemlich gut mittlerweile.
Ja.
Das ist, das ist auch, das ist auch ziemlich gut
mittlerweile. Und ich gehe auch davon aus,
dass man das in ein paar Jahren
nur noch äußerst
schwer auseinanderhalten kann.
Aber gerade was Übersetzungen angeht,
fände ich das pock. Wisst ihr was,
was ich witzig finde? Man ist, in manchen Bereichen
sind wir
deutlich besser
in dem, was man sich, also zu dem, was man
sich in irgendwelchen Science-Fiction-Filmen
vorgestellt hat für in 300 Jahren, sind wir
jetzt schon besser. Und in manchen Bereichen
haben wir noch gar nichts auf die Reihe gekriegt.
Ja, zum Beispiel, wenn man sich mal
ältere Science-Fiction-Filme anguckt,
hatten die ja auch immer irgendwelche Kommunikator-Devices,
wo sie dann halt, ich sag mal, gefunkt
haben und,
oder kommuniziert haben.
Und diese Dinger sind alle um ein Vielfaches
schlechter und, und klobiger und
größer und, und, ja,
in allen Belangen schlechter als irgendwo ein modernes
Smartphone. Also da sind wir deutlich
besser, als sich das noch Science-Fiction-Sendungen
von vor 30 Jahren vorstellen
konnten. Aber in anderen
Bereichen gar nicht. Ja, das
wundert mich nicht. Bei uns
ist es so, wir haben eine Zeiterfassung
von Microsoft-Software. Die hatte bis vor ein paar
Versionen, stand da immer noch drinnen,
wenn du die gestartet hast,
optimiert für Microsoft Internet Explorer.
Wisst ihr, was ich bei manchen
Moment, das wollt ich euch mal zeigen.
Internet of
Shit. Internet
of Shit.
Ja.
Da gibt's teilweise, gibt's teilweise
Bilder von, hier guckt doch mal Elektro.
Manche
modernen Autos
musst du jetzt Updates machen. Also du kannst
nicht einfach mit deinem Auto fahren.
Du musst jetzt einfach 15 Minuten neben stehen bleiben
und warten, bis das Software-Update durch ist.
Also das ist was, was mir persönlich ja irgendwie
widerstrebt. Ja.
Also wenn ich schon ein Auto habe,
dann möchte ich das Auto auch exakt dann
benutzen können, wann ich will.
Und der, dass man Software-Updates machen kann und
sollte, ist ja alles in Ordnung.
Eventuell, wenn ich nicht drinnen
bin. Oder aber,
dass ich sagen kann, nein,
ich fahr jetzt erst mal.
Das ist halt echt schon heftig, wenn du dir da überlegen
legst, so nach dem Motto, ich will jetzt mit dem Auto losfahren
und dann, nein, du fährst nicht los.
Du machst jetzt erst mal dein Update.
Ja, sollte
auch so sein. Das kann nicht sein, dass du da warten musst.
Aber trotzdem, also sowas ist wirklich
richtig hängen geblieben.
Toaster mit Homescreen, ja.
Warum nicht?
Nicht jedes Gerät,
was man smart machen kann, macht man smart
damit, indem man ein Display dran pappt.
Das ist auch so ein Ding. Guck mal.
Ich vermute mal, dass es äußerst sinnlos
ist, dass dieser Toaster quasi
ein Homescreen hat.
Man könnte, guckt euch, okay,
bestes Beispiel, Kühlschränke.
Es gäbe so viele coole
Möglichkeiten, Kühlschränke
smart zu machen.
Die
könnten verschiedene
Fächer haben. Man könnte das
automatisch wiegen, dass du den Stand weißt.
Man könnte
Codes scannen. Man könnte
Analyse machen, AI-technisch,
was da drin ist, was man denn als nächstes
wieder macht. Man könnte unglaublich
viel machen an Kühlschränken,
um
die zu verbessern. Aber
was zum größten Teil gemacht wird, ist,
man pappt ein Display vorne
an den Kühlschrank
und sagt,
das ist ein smarter Kühlschrank.
Oder noch schlimmer, man macht eine Kamera in den
Kühlschrank und sagt, ja, das ist jetzt ein smarter Kühlschrank.
Auf der anderen Seite gäbe es vieles und ich habe
das in Kombination so noch nicht gesehen.
Gerade was, was
man mit Codes scannen kann und sowas.
Der hat während der Fall ein
Update gemacht, ja nice.
So was. Wobei ich denke, dass es das
teilweise sogar schon geben könnte. Aber wenn nicht, ist das
auch was. Wie gesagt, was ich halt meine ist, man macht
den Kühlschrank nicht dadurch smart,
weil man einfach ein Display dran pappt oder
eine Kamera reinpackt oder sowas.
Das ist unsinnig.
Zumal ich auch der Meinung bin, wenn du wirklich
gute, smarte Heim...
Wie nennt man das?
So Heim-Elektronik-Geräte.
Wenn du da wirklich gute, smarte Geräte
bauen willst, sei es ein Kühlschrank, sei es
meinetwegen auch ein Toaster
oder eine Waschmaschine,
das Wichtigste für mich
ist, nicht, dass die
irgendwie eine Hersteller-App für Smartphones
haben, die geil aussieht
und
nur damit funktioniert.
Wichtig ist, dass das die Möglichkeit hat, in
irgendeiner Art und Weise
mit offenen Schnittstellen drauf zuzugreifen.
Weil, so in
einem Kühlschrank hast du 10, 15
Jahre. Sag ich jetzt einfach mal.
Warum sollst du den Kühlschrank austauschen, wenn
der Kühlschrank geht halt einfach.
Und wenn der kaputt ist, tauscht den aus, ansonsten behältst du ihn, bis er
verreckt. Und
dass diese Smartphone-App
in 5 Jahren
schon nicht mehr funktioniert, ist relativ hoch.
Und
bzw. dass die keine Updates mehr bekommt, ist relativ
hoch. Und
man möchte vielleicht die dann auch anderweitig
integrieren. Also es ist wichtig,
dass man möglichst simpel
auf diese smarten Geräte zugreifen
kann. Sei es
irgendeine Web-Schnittstelle, sei es MQTT.
Das einfachste dürfte tatsächlich
sein, man macht eine ganz
normale Schnittstelle.
Eine ganz normale Web-Schnittstelle,
wo man sich Sachen abrufen kann.
Weil, eins ist sicher,
normale Get-Requests,
HTTP-Get-Requests, die sind auch in 30 Jahren
noch angesagt.
Aber da haben die Hersteller keinen Bock
drauf. Besser eigene App.
Ja, dass es den Herstellern vorschreibt, ist
klar. Aber ich glaube, deswegen ist eines der Gründe,
warum es sich jetzt nicht durchsetzt.
Okay, und warum haben wir sie nicht, wenn wir sie jetzt schon haben könnten?
Ich meine,
wenn es sich lohnen würde, sowas jetzt herzustellen,
würde man das doch machen.
Da muss jemand diese Robbe...
Kennt ihr diese Robbe aus japanischen
Altersheimen, die man da streicheln
kann, diese weiße Robbe?
Kannst du ja jetzt schon machen.
Machst eine Websocket-
Verbindung und darüber dann dein Get.
Das ist zwar dann kein richtiges Get, aber du kannst
ja über Websockets denken. Theoretisch
kannst du HTTP über Websockets machen,
wenn man das will.
Ich wüsste nicht genau, warum, aber
man kann das machen, ja.
Ja, also können wir es doch nicht machen.
Weil, solange es die Technik
nicht gibt.
Gut, das kannst du zu allem sagen, dass
es im Prinzip nur eine Geldfrage ist, ja.
Also das ist nahezu
alles nur eine Geld- und Zeitfrage.
Wir könnten jetzt auch schon auf dem
Mars sein, hätten wir da
vor 60 Jahren weitergemacht.
Mit sehr viel Geld und sehr viel Manpower.
Und sehr viel Zeit.
Es ist halt immer eine Frage der
Sinnhaftigkeit, ja.
Eine Fress-Schnittstelle,
das finde ich nice.
Selbst wenn der Kühlschrank
mit SoapXML funktioniert,
ist auch okay.
Hauptsache irgendwelche offenen Schnittstellen,
wo man drauf zugreifen kann.
Also darauf wird es definitiv rauslaufen.
Also eins kann ich euch sagen,
wenn neue Technologie
sich in einem Bereich durchsetzt,
dann ist es bei Porn.
So wie man das bei VHS
gesehen hat, wie man das
bei Blu-Rays und vor allem bei VR
gesehen hat.
Ist immer so.
Und wenn es die Möglichkeit gibt,
Weeb-Roboter zu bauen,
dann gibt es die.
Als erstes.
Das erste, was es geben wird, sind
irgendwelche
Anime-Weeb-Porn-Roboter.
Ich sag's euch, das ist...
Man will's nicht wahrhaben,
aber so wird's sein.
So wird's sein,
wie bei vielen anderen Technologien auch.
Es gibt Staugsauber-Roboter
und Mähroboter.
Das stimmt auch wieder.
Ich weiß halt nicht, ob humane Roboter
überhaupt das Ding ist.
Also ich mein,
was wäre denn jetzt der Vorteil davon,
wenn du einen Roboter hast,
der mit dem Rasenmäher
durch deinen Garten fährt,
anstatt einen Mähroboter.
Außer, dass es Weirdchamp aussieht.
Danke für den Sub.
Na ja, so, was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an?
Zeig mal her.
Ja, das ist ein Gebiet, da haben wir eh große Probleme in Zukunft.
Hauptsächlich, weil es wahrscheinlich
außer Roboter irgendwann keiner mehr machen will.
Also komm, wir lassen uns
die Runde Level-Capture-Baiten.
Level-Capture-Bait ist real.
Battlefield 5 finally adds
Fan-Favorite-Mode.
Oh, finally gibt es irgendwas,
warum man das Spiel mal wieder länger als 2 Stunden spielen sollte.
Inklusive Add-On.
Wisst ihr, wie lange ich
das Add-On gespielt habe?
Add-On, die Season 1.
Ich habe es gespielt für mein Video,
5 Runden oder so, und ich habe es hier im Stream
5 Runden gespielt. Ich habe 10 Runden insgesamt gespielt
und es wieder uninstalled. Fertig.
Weil ich gar nicht weiß, ob ich es uninstalled habe.
Aber ich werde es uninstallen.
Wozu? Fertig.
Big changes by DICE bedeutet,
sie sind in eine Textdatei gegangen,
und haben...
Zeigt mal die Spielerzeilen. Ja, mache ich.
Sie sind in eine Textdatei
gegangen, aber vorne mal schnell New World lurken.
Ah, nice.
Haha, das ist doch geil.
Ich habe
am Anfang gesagt, als das Spiel rausgekommen ist,
und gerade in Deutschland haben sie eine
riesige Kampagne gefahren mit Let's-Playern,
die das spielen, und die ganzen Casual-Noobs sind
dann dahin gerannt, weil ihr Lieblings-Let's-Player das spielt,
und haben sich aufgeregt über die Server-Queues.
Ich habe noch gesagt, Leute, wartet mal,
zwei, drei Monate ab, ihr werdet euch zurückwünschen,
dass es Zeiten gibt, äh, die Zeiten wieder
mit den Server-Queues, weil
drei Monate später sind die Server leer.
Tja.
Ich habe es selten gesehen,
dass so schnell
in diesem Umfang
Spielerzahlen verloren wurden.
Man muss sich das mal vorstellen,
die sind innerhalb von eins...
Ja, stimmt nicht ganz. September, Oktober fehlt da.
Innerhalb von zwei, drei Monaten,
sagen wir mal drei Monaten,
innerhalb von drei Monaten sind die
um
850.000.
Krasser Scheiß, Alter.
So, also Battlefield, Battlefield-Zahlen.
Zeigt mal her.
Äh.
Kurz näher ein bisschen. Oh, guck mal da!
Ist wieder hoch,
und jetzt am Wochenende ist es wieder
ein bisschen hochgegangen. Guckt euch das mal an.
Also ich denke,
das wird vielleicht noch ein, zwei Wochen so gehen,
dann ist wieder Ruhe. Dann haben das alle ausprobiert,
und gut ist.
Weil Content gibt es ja nach wie vor nicht.
Und es gibt auch sonst nichts
weiter sinniger
Weise in dem Game.
Lassen wir uns mal cheap-baiten.
Und was Levelcap hier sagt, ist,
DICE ist in irgendeine Textdatei gegangen,
in irgendeine JSON-Datei,
und hat die Map-Rotation geändert. Hui!
Den Bitcoin, ja, den können wir uns angucken.
Der ist ein bisschen,
ja,
weiß ich nicht, ziemlich weit
runter
geflutscht.
So, egal.
So, vollkommen egal,
ob es die Zahlen von Origin...
Was, auf Epic? Epic gibt es auch Battlefield?
Wirklich? Tatsächlich.
Ist aber egal.
Ist, ist, ist vollkommen wurscht.
Ich meine, der Trend ist doch überall der gleiche.
Und ob es jetzt,
ich meine mal ernsthaft, ob das jetzt im Endeffekt,
ähm,
wenn man sich jetzt
das hier mal anguckt, ja,
ob es jetzt 2000 Spieler sind
auf Steam, oder,
sagen wir mal,
nochmal 2000 dabei,
für die anderen Plattformen,
das macht's jetzt nicht fett.
Also wichtig ist der Trend,
und der Trend ist überall gleich.
Wir wissen ja die Spielerzahlen von den Konsolen auch nicht,
aber wir können davon ausgehen,
dass der Trend auf den Konsolen exakt genauso ist.
Das wird's wahrscheinlich sogar bald
gratis geben.
Also, die versuchen vielleicht noch ein bisschen
mit Transactions was zu verdienen.
Ja, die Leute, die sich damals
eine Pizza gekauft haben,
ich finde das ist falsch, darüber sich jetzt Gedanken zu machen,
weil man muss sich ja überlegen, wie das war.
Man hat damals gesagt, okay,
die Pizzeria bietet für Bitcoins eine Pizza an,
und jetzt finde ich das angemessen,
das damit zu kaufen.
Da konnte doch niemand mit rechnen,
dass das 8 Jahre später richtig krass viel wert ist.
Es hätte genauso gut sein können,
dass er nie wieder was dafür bekommen hätte.
Muss man immer zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt sehen.
Weil das ist genauso,
wenn du dir irgendwelche Börsen-Crafts anguckst
und sagst, ah, hätte ich da mal
Microsoft, Apple, sonst was gekauft.
Das wusstest du ja nicht.
Das kannst du im Nachhinein
immer so einfach sagen, aber du wusstest
das ja nicht.
Mal angenommen, nächstes Jahr
geht Bitcoin auf neues
Rekordniveau,
da würden alle sagen, oh fuck, hätte ich
heute mal was gekauft. Ja, du weißt es nicht.
Es kann aber auch bei 1.700
nächstes Jahr sein.
Das sind jetzt weiter Level-Captcha-Wählen.
Auf!
Ich finde es lustig,
dass
Battlefield in letzter Zeit
eigentlich nichts
Spannendes rausbringt, aber trotzdem
diese Videos, also DICE für Battlefield
nichts Spannendes rausbringt, aber diese Videos
immer von significant
huge changes und sonst was reden.
Und in Wirklichkeit ist nichts davon significant und huge.
Ja gut, das ist gut.
Hoffentlich nur 24 Spieler.
Leute, ich sag euch was.
Wie wäre es mit einer Map, mit einfach
einer Map-Selection?
Einfach eine Map-Selection
in der Spielersuche,
weil dann könnte man einfach drei
Spielmodi anbieten und dann
könnte man dort auswählen, welche Map man
spielen will und dann würde man nur diese Map spielen,
die man spielen will, oder diese drei Maps,
die man spielen will. Ich habe gehört, so was
soll möglich sein. Aber ich glaube,
bei DICE ist einfach die Technology
noch nicht da dafür.
Stimmt, dafür gibt es auch nicht genug Spieler.
Hast du recht.
Ja.
Ja, natürlich.
Niemand spielt Portal.
Wenn ich sage, es gibt keinen Server-Browser,
habe ich jetzt schon total oft Leute gesehen
in meinen Videos, die dann sagen,
doch, doch, Max, guck mal in Portal,
da gibt es einen Server-Browser.
Die verstehen nicht, dass das was komplett anderes ist.
Also einen Server-Browser
in einem Nischenteil
des Spiels.
Ja, genau.
Also, ich glaube,
es ist nicht so einfach,
einen Server-Browser in einem Nischenteil
des Spiels
gegen den Hauptspielmodus
oder das Ding, wofür man das eigentlich
geholt hat oder, naja, wofür es beworben
wurde,
wo die Leute drauf scharf sind,
den Hauptspielmodus oder die Hauptspielkategorie.
Da gibt es keinen Server-Browser.
Und nur weil es da in Portal irgendwie so was
Nischenmäßiges gibt,
so what?
Also, eins muss man da sagen,
DICE hat das in dem Fall ja echt perfektioniert.
Die können viel reden über nichts,
nichts.
Also, die reden viel über sehr wenig Inhalt.
Was möchte denn DICE bitteschön an weekly,
weekly, weekly, seriously,
weekly Roadmaps raushauen?
Das Spiel ist acht Monate alt
und hat kaum neue Sachen
oder hat im Endeffekt nichts wirklich bekommen.
Ja, Voice Chat, hui.
Ja, nen Scoreboard.
Aber das ist doch nichts,
an Inhalt.
Das Spiel hat in acht Monaten nichts zu bekommen.
Was wollen die denn in ihre weekly
Roadmap schreiben?
8.30 Uhr gehe ich aufs Klo.
9.30 Uhr gehe ich was futtern.
10.30 Uhr mache ich ein Video
auf YouTube.
A Day in DICE Developers
Life.
Was soll auf dieser Roadmap draufstehen?
Also, Inhalt zum Game
kann es ja schlecht sein.
Ich weiß nicht,
ich hab das Gefühl,
dass es einen neuen Game gibt.
Ich glaube,
ich habe das Gefühl,
dass es einen neuen Game gibt,
aber ich weiß nicht genau,
wie es sich vorstellt.
Ich weiß nicht,
Ich glaube,
dass es sich vorstellt.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob es sich vorstellt.
Aber die tauschen einfach mal
die halbe Map aus.
So, zwischen Updates.
Und dann sagt DICE, ja, wir könnten uns überlegen,
ob wir nicht auf dieser Map drei neue Kisten
platzieren. Also, die Roadmap
bei Warzone ist, wir tauschen zwischen
Updates einfach mal die halbe Map aus
und bringen eine neue Map mit rein.
Und die Roadmap bei Battlefield ist,
ja, man könnte drei Kisten platzieren.
Und der nächste Punkt
in unserer Roadmap ist, dass wir die Roadmap
für nächste Woche erstellen.
bertraibe den Player Visibility,
Caldera wird neue Mikropunkte
und mehr Leurupe-Lehrer
und einen neuen geheimen Untergrundball bekommen.
Bethesda-Boss Todd Howard
sagte in einer Interview, dass
das nächste Fallout-Spiel nicht jakiś Zeit
mehr auf kommen würde.
Er hat verurteilt, dass Fallout 5
das Elder Scrolls 6 folgen wird,
was noch immer
Es wurde vor vier Jahren angekündigt, und zwar wie? Sie haben einen Schriftzug gezeigt und haben dabei das Elder Scrolls Main Theme für drei Tastendrücke angespielt.
So, fertig. Nice. Und seitdem nie wieder was von gehört.
Ja, gut. Seriously.
Ähm.
Wenn die kein Spiel rausbringen mit Mod-Support, ist es ja ins... Also das muss man ihnen ja tatsächlich lassen. Skyrim ist eines der besten Modding-Plattformen aller Zeiten.
Erinnert mich ein bisschen daran, an Half-Life 1, was es da für tausende geile Mods gab. Also von den Möglichkeiten her.
Da gibt's so Sachen wie Enderal, wo sie quasi das komplette Spiel, wo sie quasi nur das Framework drumherum genommen haben und ein komplett eigenes Spiel gebaut haben.
Also...
Das machen die schon richtig.
Das sorgt ja letztendlich auch für Langlebigkeit in den Games.
Und, ähm, dass man sich da nicht drauf verlassen muss, dass sie das mit Inhalt füllen für die nächsten zehn Jahre, ist ja auch gut.
Zum Beispiel Games wie Mario Kart.
Sag ich jetzt nicht von ungefähr, weil es gab ja eine Custom-Strecke für Mario Kart als Mod, die optisch noch nicht so hundertprozentig an die Original-Strecken greift.
Weil sie noch Probleme haben mit der Beleuchtung.
Aber überlegt euch mal, wie cool das wäre, könnte man einfach mit ordentlichen Mod-Tools Mario Kart-Strecken erstellen.
Das wäre eines der beliebtesten Games der Welt.
Das wäre das Spiel auf Steam, äh, das Spiel auf Twitch.
Das wäre einfach der Riesen-Hype, wenn es dafür Möglichkeiten gäbe, eigene Strecken zu erstellen.
Aber was macht Nintendo? Nix.
Nintendo nix und bringt irgendwie die Mario-Kart-Tour-Strecken leicht angepasst dafür raus. Nice.
Aber überlegt euch mal, wie das Spiel komplett durch die Decke gehen würde, könntest du in Mario Kart Custom-Strecken erstellen.
Und ich meine damit nicht, ähm, dass sie einen Mario-Kart-Maker machen sollen.
Das meine ich damit gar nicht.
Es ist nämlich ein Unterschied, ob du einen, tja, Mario-Kart-Maker, Dungeon-Maker oder sonst was hast.
Oder ob du einfach Zugriff auf die Entwicklungstools hast.
Wenn du dir nämlich Skyrim anguckst oder auch, äh, davor, wenn man sich mal die, ähm, wie hießen die Baldur's Gate-Leute?
Black Isle Studios? Bin ich mir gar nicht mehr sicher.
Äh, wenn man sich die Neverwinter Nights Mod-Tools anguckt und sowas, da hast du gesehen, dass die Leute das Spiel zum großen Teil auch mit diesen Tools entwickelt haben.
Und das ist ein Unterschied.
Ob du den Leuten einen, tja, Casual-freundlichen...
Varian Games waren die Divinity-Tools. Das sind wieder andere.
Ähm, ich meine nicht, die Baldur's Gate 3 machen. Ich meine die, die alten Dinger.
Und, oder, oder guckt ihr, guckt ihr Source-Engine-Sachen an. Genau.
Ähm, das ist kein Level-Editor für Casuals wie Mario Maker.
Sondern das sind halt die Tools, mit denen die Entwickler zum größten Teil auch die Inhalte dafür erstellt haben.
Das ist ein Unterschied. Und da kannst du halt viel mehr machen.
Das kann nicht jeder Kack-Noob, aber es muss auch nicht jeder Kack-Noob Strecken erstellen.
Belegt euch mal, du hättest wirklich die Möglichkeit, mit ordentlichen Tools, was ja fan-made mittlerweile halbwegs sogar geht für Mario Kart.
Also Nintendo mag das halt nicht.
Ähm, du hättest wirklich offiziell die Möglichkeit, richtig neue Strecken mit ordentlichen Entwicklungstools für Mario Kart zu erstellen.
Alter, das Spiel würde auch auf Twitch...
Das würde überall komplett durch die Decke gehen.
Weil das ist einfach ein ultra spaßiges Game.
Und wenn es da jetzt noch abgedrehten geilen Fan-Content gäbe...
Und man kann sich...
Nintendo kann sich das jetzt gar nicht ausdenken, was den Fans alles einfallen würde.
Ja, das erste, was es gäbe, wäre Prophunt in Mario Kart.
Bin ich mir sicher, das ist immer einer der ersten Modi, die es gibt.
Ja, da kannst du dann...
Ich bin auf der Map versteckt, ich bin irgendein Shy Guy, der da oben auf der Pyramide rumläuft oder so.
Ähm, da gäbe es...
Ähm, da gäbe es die krassesten Mods überhaupt.
Und das würde das Spiel...
Das würde komplett durch die Decke gehen.
Ist natürlich die Frage, ob Nintendo dann in ein paar Jahren ein neues Mario Kart verkaufen könnte.
Oder so viele Leute noch sich die Strecken-DLCs kaufen würden, ja.
Das ist richtig, das ist richtig, ja.
Ja, klar, das stimmt schon.
Aber es würde das Spiel unglaublich langlebig und unglaublich gehypt machen.
Egal, wir lassen es weiter, Jibain.
Also Mod-Support ist immer noch eines der geilsten, also gut gemachter Mod-Support, ja.
Mod-Support muss ja gar nicht...
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr was das...
Wisst ihr eigentlich, warum so viele Spiele früher Mod-Support hatten?
Das war kein Mod-Support im eigentlichen Sinn.
Die Entwickler haben einfach ihre Entwicklertools dabei gelegt.
Half-Life 1 hattest du... Worldcraft hieß das glaube ich noch.
Worldcraft?
Ja, Worldcraft hieß das Ding in Half-Life 1.
Heute heißt es Hammer, früher hieß es Worldcraft.
Ähm, die haben einfach ihre Entwicklertools dabei gelegt.
Und...
Fast jedes Echtzeitstrategiespiel damals, guckt euch auch die alten Command & Conquer Teile an,
die hatten einen Editor dabei.
Und das war zu 90%, vielleicht nicht alle Features komplett, aber das war zu 90% eben der Editor,
mit dem die Missionen für dieses Spiel erstellt wurden, vom Hersteller.
Also das war kein Mod-Support in dem Sinn, dass man gesagt hätte, ja, wir machen das jetzt extra.
Die haben einfach ihre Entwicklertools freigegeben.
Sachen wie Warcraft 3, wenn...
Also die ganzen Warcraft 3 Mods wären ja gar nicht möglich gewesen,
mit einem minimalistischen, casual-freundlichen Editor.
WPM, ja, habe ich schon.
Ich bin nicht sonderlich schnell im Schreiben.
Vor allem nicht fehlerfrei.
So, und das war halt richtig geil, deswegen gab es da auch so viel geilen Content.
Und deswegen konntest du damals quasi jahrelang Spiele spielen.
Weil es einfach...
Poggers Content am laufenden Band und...
Und von Leuten, die das Spiel kannten und wussten, wie man gute Sachen macht, gab.
Es gab auch viel...
Es gab sehr viel Müll-Content.
Also 90% der Mods, würde ich sagen, waren Müll.
Aber ist egal, es gab einfach saumäßig viele.
Und auch richtig gute, ja.
Ja.
Ego CS ist ja im Prinzip ein Mod.
War ursprünglich gewesen.
Dota auch, genau.
Also, wie gesagt, das ist...
Das Beste, wie man Spiele langlebig machen kann.
Und es war halt früher mehr oder weniger normal.
Weil die ihre Entwicklertools mitgebracht haben.
Und die haben halt dann gesagt, ja, entweder ihr arbeitet euch da ein, oder ihr habt Pech gehabt.
Aber du hattest halt die umfangreichen Möglichkeiten, was zu machen.
...Included in DLCs and re-releases.
Howard wants Starfield to act...
Ohne Scheiß, Overwatch wäre ein so viel geileres Game, jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Overwatch könnte eines der besten...
Competitive...
Casual...
Könnte eines der besten Spiele für alle sein.
Gäbe es die Entwicklertools, beziehungsweise gäbe es die Möglichkeit, ordentliche Custom-Maps zu machen.
Weil man muss halt sagen, die Overwatch-Maps sind halt zur Hälfte Ultra-Kacke.
Gerade die ganzen 2CP-Dinger.
Also gut, dass die rausfliegen.
Und Blizzard kann keine Maps bauen.
Also ich finde, die Overwatch-Maps...
Die sind halt vom Detailgrad...
Und vom Design her...
Sind die cool.
Also Art-Abteilung hat Blizzard.
Aber die Maps sind vom Gameplay her...
Rotz.
Ganz ehrlich.
Das ist meine Meinung von den Overwatch-Maps.
Es gibt ein paar Maps, die sind okay.
Kings Row zum Beispiel, finde ich, ist ganz nice.
Aber ansonsten, die meisten Maps sind einfach...
Langweilige...
Schlauch-Level...
Ohne...
Klasse.
Also Overwatch-Maps sind einfach total...
Langweilig...
Zum größten Teil schlecht designte Shooter-Maps.
Könnte man wirklich gute...
Könnte man wirklich Maps entwerfen...
Für Overwatch.
Wäre das eines der besten Spiele der letzten Jahre.
Und wäre es immer noch.
Es wäre auch nicht so untergegangen.
Weil Blizzard nix...
Weil Blizzard nix an Content rausbringt.
Es ist doch nicht ohne Grund so...
Dass StarCraft...
Die Maps, die dort gespielt werden...
Die wechseln ja auch immer wieder.
Niemand spielt Blizzard-Maps.
Das sind alles Custom-Maps.
Und der Map-Pool wechselt da auch regelmäßig.
Die ganzen StarCraft-Maps sind alles Custom-Maps.
Das gleiche.
Das gilt auch für Modding.
Er hat gesagt, Starfield sei ein Traum für seine Modding-Community.
Die Resident Evil-Franchise hatte diese Woche einige spannende Announcements.
Resident Evil Village bekommt eine neue Expansion...
namens Shadows of Rose.
Es wird aufgrund des Protagonisten Daughter von der Basis-Game basiert.
Capcom hat gesagt, dass die neue DLC viel schwieriger ist als die Basis-Game.
Village bekommt auch eine 3-Person-Mode...
die es spielen wird wie eine Kombination der originalen Resident Evil-Games...
und ihrer modernen Remakes.
All diese neuen Inhalte sind als Teil der Golden Edition-Bundle vorgesehen...
die am 28. Oktober startet.
Highly Realistic Tactical FPS Ready or Not...
wurde mit dieser Erklärung temporär von Steam verlistet.
Das Spiel wurde eine Woche nach dem Entwickler-Nightclub-Level...
ein Mass-Shoot-Event angezeigt.
Die Devs sagen, Valve hat noch nicht klargestellt, warum das Spiel verlost wurde...
aber sie arbeiten daran, die Situation zu lösen.
Es ist wahrscheinlich so, dass das Spiel die Dedikation zum Realismus...
Wie ist denn das eigentlich?
Meine blöde Frage.
Hatte schon jemand mal die Variante, er hat ein Steam-Game gekauft...
runtergeladen und dann wurde es von Steam genommen.
Was passiert dann?
Kann man es dann noch spielen?
Kann man es nur nicht mehr runterladen?
Wird es deinstalliert lokal bei einem?
Kann man es anklicken, aber nicht mehr starten?
Man kann es nur nicht neu kaufen, oder wie?
Achso.
Also man kann es bloß nicht mehr kaufen.
... zu weit für Valve.
Ready or Not-Levels und Szenarien sind designt...
um Real-Welt-Situationen zu reflektieren...
ohne sie zu glorifizieren.
Offensichtlich nutzen die Devs...
extrem sensitives Thema, um ihr Spiel zu erschaffen.
Also werden sie natürlich Probleme mit ihren Publishern haben.
Apex Legends Mobile hat die Mobile-Gaming-Szene dominiert...
seit es im letzten Monat eröffnet wurde.
Diese Woche wurden die Spieler...
zu den ersten Szenen...
... gespielt.
Ich stell mir die Steuerung auf Mobile...
oder cheatet jeder mit dem Controller?
Spielt es einfach jeder mit dem Controller?
Und fickt die ganzen...
Plebs am Touchscreen weg?
Oder wie ist das?
Weil am Touchscreen...
kann man das am Touchscreen gescheit spielen...
geht das überhaupt?
Es gibt auch ein Video vom Haupt-Game.
Loba ist jetzt zur Verfügung...
aber ihre Chancen sind nicht die gleichen wie die auf PC und Konsole.
Sie kann durch den Battle Pass geschlossen werden.
Diese Vorstellung hat Fan-Spezialisten...
über die anderen Helden des Haupt-Games...
in der Mobile-Version in der Zukunft.
Sony arbeitet auf eine neue Pro-Kontrolle...
für den PlayStation 5.
Diese Worte kamen von Leaker Tom Henderson...
der sagt, er habe das Prototypen...
dieses neuen Pro-Kontrollers gesehen.
Er sagt, es wird...
eine Analyse-Stick...
mit Sticks,
Steckerstöcken...
Hinterstöcken...
Rückzügen...
und Schrauben.
Die steckigen Analyse-Stöcke...
werden als Schraubendreher...
eigentlich nur gewechselt...
wenn sie etwas entwickeln...
wie Stecktritt-Untertitel...
oder einfach wegschmeißen.
Ubisoft hat erneut...
das involvehrte...
das Future of Assassin's Creed...
IM September.
Fans spekulieren daran...
dass dieses Event zu dem Auslöser...
im rumäherten...
Assassin's Creed Infinity Game...
kommt...
ein freier Spiel...
in Multi-Ära-Live-Service...
Genau...
bitte bitte...
oder?
Das hört sich wieder nach Ultra an. Wir wollen ganz viel Geld machen, haben aber eigentlich keine gute Idee für das Game an.
Es gibt Fans, die spekulieren über die Eröffnungszeit des Spiels. Der sehr erwartete Sequel, God of War Ragnarok, wurde in 2021 geöffnet, aber wurde in diesem Jahr zurückgelegt.
Ein Online-Store hat die Eröffnungszeit von Ragnarok-Merchandise mit einem Eröffnungszeitpunkt von Oktober 2022 gelistet.
Laut Entwicklern auf Twitter wird das Spiel nicht wieder gedelayt werden, also wird ein Oktober-Eröffnungszeitpunkt mehr wahrscheinlich sein.
District 9 und Elysium-Direktor Neill Blockkamp wird einen Gran Turismo-Film durchdrehen.
Es wird im August 2023 wiedergeleitet, aber die Berichte zeigen, dass es nicht die gewünschte Videospiel-Adaptation ist.
Stattdessen folgt der Film einem Teenager-Gran Turismo-Spieler, dessen Spielskillen ihn dazu führen, ein professioneller Rennfahrer-Driver zu werden.
Außerdem sind nur wenige zusätzliche Details bekannt, aber die Produktion bei Columbia Pictures beginnt bald.
Es wird von den gleichen Produzenten geführt, die den letzten Uncharted-Film gemacht haben.
Da hab ich ja keine großen Hoffnungen, wenn das die Uncharted-Leute sind.
Live-Stream Activision Blizzard confirmed that the sequel would be an always-on, constantly evolving, free-to-play game.
It'll drop the original's Loot-Box-Model in favor of a Battle Pass and an in-game store.
Each season will run for nine weeks and include either a new map or a new hero every time.
Not to mention new weekly challenges, cosmetics...
Moment, Moment, Moment!
Die wollen alle neun Wochen eine neue Map und einen neuen Held releasen?
Oder, oder einen neuen Held?
Das geht nicht.
Wir haben, also, wir haben bei DICE gesehen, das ist nicht möglich.
Also es ist wirklich wörtlich genommen unmöglich.
Das geht, das geht gar nicht.
Chico verdeckt die oberste Zeile hier, was macht Chico denn für Dinger hier?
So, jetzt verdeckt Chico nicht mal die oberste Zeile.
Ja, aber das, was ist denn mit denen los? DICE sagt nein, genau, das geht gar nicht.
... in new modes.
Blizzard aims to deliver more content to players more frequently with Overwatch 2
compared to the first title.
It's set to launch into early access on October 4th this year.
Before we move on to our final video today, don't forget to go ahead and hit that subscribe button.
It's a great way to support the channel and it'll make sure you don't miss any upcoming news content.
And also, drop us a like if you feel inclined.
The release date for Survival FPS Stalker 2 has recently been pushed back to 2023.
This is because the development team, GSC Game World, was based in the Ukraine.
The extended Xbox and Bethesda showcase this week included a short video about what the developers have been dealing with since the Russia invasion began.
The video shows the bombed-out offices of the developers as well as different devs in uniform.
Also, das ist glaube ich tatsächlich eines der wenigen Sachen, wo ich das tatsächlich direkt nachvollziehen kann, warum man das Spiel verschiebt.
Ich meine, wenn du vor deinem Rechner sitzt und irgendjemand schießt in dein Büro,
dass das zu Verzögerungen führen kann, kann ich mir doch schon gut vorstellen.
The community manager for the game also now uses a bathroom for an office.
The studio is currently transitioning to a new office space in Prague.
They have stated that once things are up and running, development on Stalker 2 will resume.
And that wraps it up for this week in gaming.
As always, guys, thank you so much for watching and I'll catch you next time.
This is LevelCap signing off.
Ah.
Ja, aber trotzdem.
Es dauert Monate für eine neue Map und einen neuen Held.
Es kann nicht sein, dass das innerhalb von ein paar Wochen passiert.
What happens if you cut off CPU pins?
Also, ich vermute mal, folgendes wird passieren.
Entweder passiert gar nichts, weil es irgendein nicht benutzter Pin ist,
oder aber der Rechner geht erst gar nicht richtig an, beziehungsweise startet nicht richtig.
Ich glaube, dazwischen gibt es nicht so viel, würde ich jetzt mal vermuten.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, moderne CPUs haben gar keine Pins mehr.
Wie sieht es bei AMD aus?
Haben die noch Pins? Nee, oder?
Ich hatte schon lange keine AMD CPU mehr.
Mal kurz meine CPU-Auslastung checken.
AMD hat Pins tatsächlich.
Nee, es gibt keine Pins mehr. Also Intel hat schon seit Jahren keine Pins mehr.
Okay, gucken wir mal, was passiert.
What happens if you cut off the pins of a CPU?
The result might surprise you.
Hey everyone, I'm Mr. Yeaster and today, let's find out.
Zu laut.
This here is an AMD FX 6300, which is one of the older AMD chips.
I think it was released in 2012, 2013, something like that.
And if we flip it over, we can see that there's hundreds of these tiny little pins extruding from the underside.
When pins stick out of the processor like this, it's what's known as PGA, or Pin Grid Array,
a fairly common trait of modern AMD CPUs.
The alternative to PGA is LGA, or Land Grid Array, like most modern Intel processors.
On the right, you can see there's no actual pins extruding out, but instead have all of these connective pads.
And while today it's common for most AMD processors to utilize PGA and most Intel processors to utilize LGA,
both companies have historically tried both types of grid array designs.
And if you go back far enough, you can actually find Intel processors that have pins.
So this is kind of hard to tell, because I've polished off half of this chip.
Das war früher normal, dass die Pins haben.
But this is an Intel CPU, and if we take it out of the socket, you can see that it actually does have pins.
There are pros and cons and differences between the PGA and LGA processors,
one of them requiring different compatible motherboard socket designs.
For example, if you have a PGA processor, it will need a compatible motherboard socket so that these pins can actually slot in correctly.
For example, this FX6300 can't actually fit into an LGA compatible socket.
As you can see, there's nowhere for these pins to go.
And another major difference between PGA and LGA is the fragility of the processors themselves.
So, coming back to our AMD FX6300,
there are in fact over a thousand pins extruding from this underside,
each of which are responsible for a very specific task when plugged into the receiving ports on the motherboard.
Now, all of these tiny pins are notoriously easy to damage,
which is why CPUs come packaged in these protective, clean shelves.
What these do is they leave a little gap of air so that the pins don't actually come in contact with anything.
So that way, if you do happen to drop it,
Ideally, nothing should be damaged.
And in our case, it seemed to do the job. No bent pins here.
Now, you've probably heard PC horror stories of someone accidentally dropping one of these expensive processors and bending a bunch of the pins.
And while this is a real problem and best to avoid altogether,
does a CPU actually need every single one of these pins to be intact in order to function?
To find out, it's time to perform some CPU surgery
for the process of actually cutting off one of these pins.
Warum nimmt der nicht einen kleinen Seitenschneider?
Ich meine, mit Schere wird's ein bisschen schwierig, oder?
We're gonna need a knife.
Oder ein Messer.
Okay, maybe a smaller knife.
Ein kleiner Seitenschneider wäre nicht verkehrt.
Like an exacto blade. Perfect.
Now that we're all set, this pin right here is gonna be our victim.
As always, please don't try this at home.
And with that, the surgery is complete.
Think of it as a haircut for the CPU.
So with this single pin cleanly removed from the processor,
let's install it into our system and see what happens.
Wahrscheinlich geht es einfach, je nachdem was es halt für ein Pin ist.
Wetten?
Wetten, der hat sich vor dem Video irgendeinen Plan angeguckt, welcher Pin was ist.
Weil es wäre blöd gewesen für den, wenn er das Video erstellt
und der erste Pin schon die CPU kaputt macht.
I just plugged in both of those USBs first time.
That's incredible. I should go play the lottery.
Alright, with our system assembled, let's power it on.
In this instance, to power this on, I'm just gonna short out the power pins
on the motherboard using a metal object, in this case a screwdriver.
Hab ich auch schon öfters gemacht.
We can see that it spins to life instantly, which is a good sign.
Which means that the CPU isn't failing enough to completely stop it from powering on.
Moment, moment. Powering on?
Macht der ja sogar selbst, wenn keine CPU...
Wobei, wenn gar keine drinsteckt, weiß ich nicht.
Aber dass es einfach angeht, das ist, glaube ich, relativ unabhängig von der CPU.
Actually boots. That's awesome. Let's go.
And if we look in the BIOS, we can see that it's clearly being recognized as an AMD FX 6300,
which is exactly what it should be recognized as.
However, let's take this one step further, load into Windows,
and see if we can stress test this to see if anything breaks.
So with that, let's get into Windows.
Also ich gehe stark davon aus, wenn das bis hierhin kommt, geht das auch.
Now that Windows is loaded up, let's put this guy through some stress tests.
To monitor my hardware, I like to use a program called MSI Afterburner
to look at this type of stress thing and things like that.
We'll let it run here for a little bit to see if there's any issues.
Typically if a CPU is unstable, it'll fail one of these tests and completely shut down the computer.
Now that the stress test has been running for a little while,
it's clear that the system is completely stable.
It should be able to run as normal without this pin being in place.
And what was the actual responsibility of this particular pin?
And to dig into that, let's take a look at the actual design schematic for this particular processor.
And every single one of these squares coordinates to one of the physical pins
and describes what its function is.
Some of the pins are responsible for measuring voltage,
other pins are responsible for measuring memory,
but what was the responsibility of the pin that we cut off?
As a reminder, the pin we cut off was the farthest right pin on the top row
if we orient the CPU with the golden corner in the top right.
This schematic is actually top down, so if you want to look at it...
Der Pin ist doch noch dran?
Ne, ist ab.
Corner in the top right.
Hab nix gesagt.
This schematic is actually top down,
so if you want to look at it bottom up from the pin perspective,
you have to flip it around, so all of the words will be backwards.
But if we look at the top right,
which in this case, the pin that we cut off is responsible for VSS,
and what does that stand for?
Ist das Spannung, oder?
If we take a look at the functional data sheet,
we eventually will find VSS right here,
which is responsible for grounding...
Ja, dass es da noch geht, ist ja klar,
ist ja nicht der einzige Ground Pin.
If we go back real quick,
you can see that there's plenty of VSSs to go around.
There's a lot of these green squares,
which all have that same purpose.
So, the fact that we cut off one of the grounding pins
does not prevent the other ones from continuing.
Cringe Design, warum machen die nicht nur ein Ground Pin?
...to ground.
Therefore, because this pin here had one of the most common
and duplicated tasks throughout the rest of the CPU,
its absence does not prevent the computer from running as normal,
as we saw in our experiment.
Therefore, if you do happen to drop your PGA-CPU
and damage some of the pins,
don't lose all hope right away.
Pins can be pushed back into place,
and if you're extremely lucky,
any pins that break off completely might just have some backup.
As they say, they're strength in numbers.
Thanks for joining me on this experiment.
If you enjoyed it, consider subscribing to my YouTube channel
or following me on TikTok.
I'll see you in the next video.
Bye!
Er muss wahrscheinlich echt aufpassen,
weil das Volk willst du hier nicht rumfliegen haben.
Jetzt wissen wir auch Bescheid,
wie das mit Honig im Weltraum ist.
Can Ice Cubes replace your CPU cooler?
Warum nicht?
Wichtig ist, dass das alles genug Kontakt hat
zum Wärmeabführen.
Du kannst theoretisch deinen CPU-Cooler
auch replacen mit fünf Fiber-Intern,
die einfach nur pusten
gegen ein Kühlelement.
Das wär's doch.
Man ordert sich über Fiber
fünf Inter,
und die müssen dann deinen CPU-Cooler
pusten die ganze Zeit.
Das geht bestimmt auch.
Es ist halt die Frage, ob es sinnvoll ist.
Eher nicht, würde ich sagen.
Genauso will ich wie mit Eiswürfeln
seinen CPU-Kühler kühlen.
Wobei, gibt es Fiber?
Gibt es sowas wie Fiber auch für
ähm, echte Jobs?
Also,
kann ich jemanden auf Fiber ordern,
der meinen Rasen mäht?
Zum Beispiel?
Ich habe auf Fiber schon Leute gesehen,
die haben in ihrem Profil drin stehen gehabt,
ich mache alles.
Klingt immer ein bisschen
missverständlich, ja?
Gibt es auch Fiber?
Die schreiben, sie machen alles.
Und ob die dann auch den Rasen mähen?
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, ich glaube,
ich möchte nicht so einen random Fiber-Dude haben,
der bei mir auf dem Kunststück den Rasen mäht.
Mit flüssigem Stickstoff
kann man auch eine CPU kühlen, ja.
Man kann theoretisch
sogar mit flüssigem Wasserstoff
eine CPU kühlen, wobei flüssiges Wasserstoff
eine ganze Ecke schwieriger herzustellen ist.
Das muss sehr kalt sein, ich glaube,
du musst irgendwie auf 20 Kelvin
oder so runter, dass das
flüssig, normal ist ja Gas, dass das flüssig
wird. Flüssiges Helium
ist 3 Kelvin.
Noch besser. So, was schauen wir uns als nächstes an?
Every apartment
needs this upgrade.
Okay, wir gucken mal kurz rein, ob das irgendwas ist,
was ich interessant finde.
Okay, lass mich raten.
Der lötet
über
mehrere Zwischenschritte
einen ESP32 an seine
Tür-Gegensprechanlage und lässt sich da
eine WhatsApp-Nachricht schicken.
Das ist ja easy, das habe ich auch schon gemacht.
Allerdings nicht über WhatsApp.
Okay.
Deswegen haben wir ja im Stream auch mal den
Doorbell-Champ programmiert,
der nicht nur es auf
mein Handy weiterleiten kann, wenn es klingelt,
sondern sogar die Kamera mit rein multipliziert.
Das heißt, ich kann es auch
in den Call-Stream
verwenden.
Das heißt, ich bekomme jetzt einen Anruf auf
dem Handy, kann dran gehen
und sehe die Kamera vom Hoftor.
...
kann man remote aufmachen? ne ich habe keinen Toröffner
ok zeig her was
das ist ein ESP2866
das sieht aus wie ein stinknormaler D1 Mini
sowas in der Richtung, fertig
also das ist tatsächlich nicht so einfach
ich hatte ja auch mal ein ESP32 dran
das zu powern war tatsächlich nicht so einfach
ich hatte noch glücklicherweise freie Adern
und habe dann 12 Volt Netzteil unten im Keller dran gehängt
und dann jeweils mit dem Spannungswandler runter
auf 3,3 Volt für den Controller
aber mittlerweile habe ich ein Raspberry Pi unten im Keller stehen
direkt mit einem Analog-Digital-Konverter dran
und da sind die Drähte drauf von der Türgegensprechanlage
da habe ich das Problem nicht mehr
und da läuft dann auch das Programm was den Handyanruf macht drauf
aber all in all, wie ich schon gesagt habe,
dieser Plan sah super einfach aus
ja würde ich auch sagen
also lasst uns mit einem kurzen Blick auf das Interkommunikationssystem schauen
ja exakt so sieht es bei mir auch aus
also zwar für andere Hersteller, aber es sieht sehr sehr ähnlich aus innen drin
die restlichen 2 Kabel sind für das Twin-Bus-System
das auf dem PCB erwähnt wird
aber bei mir sind es nur 3 Kabel
... zwischen den Kabel, die für die anderen Kabel hier nicht vorhanden sind
und in dem Fall
in case you're wondering why I taped a magnet in front of the PCB
warum da ein Magnet dranhängt, das kann ich euch sagen
bevor er das sagt
das ist damit das Ding denkt, der Hörer ist aufgehängt
das geht bei mir auch über ein Magnet
der Hörer hat ein Magnet drinnen und dahinter ist ein Schalter
und wenn du den Hörer aufhängst, dann schaltet es halt
... dann lass ich dir sagen, dass es simuliert, dass die Telefon-Parte des Interkomms
noch da ist
sag ich doch, dass der Hörer draufhängt
aber egal, am wichtigsten sind diese Kabel
die hier sind
die auf dem Boden sind
und direkt daneben ist mein gewünschter Ring-Signal
wie ihr seht, ist dieser Pin normalerweise auf dem Boden-Level
aber wenn jemand die Tür aufhängt, steigt die Voltage nach 5 Volt nachher
hey, das ist ja richtig gut
nicht so kacke wie bei meinem System
wo es 24 bis 30 Volt immer hin und her schwankt
weil der Hersteller komische Dinger macht
welches genau der Indikator ist, warum der Hersteller komische Dinger macht
welche Formen der Teller sind Youre
Gente xD
Dieər Bordeaux
們
Aber ich habe ja auch keine Rito.
Do this to your Nintendo 64.
Okay, we have a problem.
So you can't...
Nope. Nope. Nope.
Brain Booster Pills.
What the fuck?
Haben wir das nicht schon geguckt, das Video?
Und haben wir das...
Warum wollte da gerade ein Pop-Up gehen?
This is...
Haben wir das nicht schon geguckt?
Doch, doch, das haben wir schon geguckt.
Ups.
Oh nein.
Okay, was können wir uns sonst noch angucken?
24 Destroyed MacBook.
Which Battlefield Games are dead?
War natürlich für DS.
Was? Timelapse.
Ants vs. Marshmallow.
Wurde mir vorhin empfohlen.
Ich weiß nicht warum.
Wirklich unterhaltsames Video.
Okay.
Wenn der Chat das sagt...
Video Game Industry?
No.
Nuh-uh.
Today, Square Enix is...
The fuck?
Okay.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich muss mir erstmal angucken, wie Ants vs. Marshmallow funktioniert.
Zeig her.
Das ist ein Marshmallow?
Das sieht für mich aus wie...
Jetzt muss ich mal überlegen, wie...
Ein Schaum...
Schaum-Süß-Waren-Produkt aus.
Schokoladen-überzogenes Schaumgebäck, genau.
Bleiben die da nicht hängen?
Ein Dickmann, genau.
Da tut sich aber nicht so viel.
Da muss man ein bisschen schneller vorspuren.
Ah, doch.
Sind die blöd?
Warum krabbeln die denn da rein?
Warum machen die das nicht von außen nach innen?
Warum krabbeln die denn da rein, Alter?
Die bleiben da drin festkleben und kratzen ab.
Egal.
Es geht hier nicht um das Leben des Einzelnen wahrscheinlich.
Mal gucken, wie viele Ameisen draufgehen bei dem Versuch, das Ding zu clearen.
Guck hier.
Guck, die ersten sind schon stuck.
Die ersten sind schon stuck.
Seht ihr es hier?
Die ersten sind stuck.
Guck, die ersten sind schon dead.
Guck, schon hier irgendwie drei Stück gleich dead.
Und direkt, guck mal.
Dead, dead und direkt abtransportiert.
Dead.
Gleich weiterverwertet.
Die Beine sind noch da, ja.
Da sind erstaunlich viele Beine, die hier rumhängen.
Da geht es halt wirklich nicht darum, dass der Einzelne überlebt.
Die Masse macht es.
Guck mal, und wenn das Ding hier zusammenfällt, da sind doch garantiert, ich meine, okay,
das fällt ja nicht instant runter, aber hier, das fällt ja innerhalb von ein paar Stunden
runter bei der Geschwindigkeit, ja.
Aber guck mal, da waren doch garantiert welche drunter, als das runtergefallen ist.
Ja, guck mal, da, da sind, da sind schon, da hat, da hat es auch irgendwelche verschüttet
gleich.
Ja, guck mal, das ganze Ding ist voll mit Ameisenleichen.
Aber, egal, juckt, juckt sie nicht.
30 Tage, boah, guck mal, 33 Tage, bis das Ding abtransportiert wurde, sind nur Ameisenleichen
zurückgeblieben.
40 Tage, bis das Ding leer war, Alter.
Jetzt wissen wir auch, wie Ameisen versus Marshmallows aussieht, alles klar.
30 Tage und es hat nicht geschimmelt.
Das ist wahrscheinlich so voller Zucker, da, da, da kommt kein Schimmel mehr rein.
Bacon Egg?
B-L-T Supreme?
Ne, wir gucken jetzt kein Kekona-BBQ-Pit-Boys-Video.
Wuhu!
Oder was sagt der immer?
Wuii!
Ich kann es, ich kann es, ich bin nicht, bin ich nicht Kekona genug dazu?
Nachher, nachher, nur wenn es mit dem Originalsprecher ist.
Ja, es ist, es ist mit dem Originalsprecher, alles gut.
Nachher, nachher.
Okay, was haben wir sonst noch?
Okay.
Was haben wir sonst noch so zu bieten?
Aha.
Hm.
Was?
Head-on-Train-Crash-Compilation 2021.
Also, das sind Sachen, die wurden mir vorher empfohlen, ich habe keine Ahnung warum, aber
wir gucken uns jetzt ein paar Trains crashen an anscheinend.
Okay.
Na dann.
Train-Crash.
Moment, Leute.
Brauchen wir die passende.
Wo ist Mario Kart?
Oh.
Oh, das wird, das wird eng.
Das wird eng.
Oh.
Mock AS.
Okay.
Leute, das ist der Moment.
Das ist der Moment, wo ich tatsächlich mal so einen Hammer nehmen würde vom Fenster
und aus dem Zug springen.
Wenn ich sehe, dass wir direkt frontal auf einem anderen Zug, siehst du ja normalerweise
nicht von innen.
Aber ich würde einfach mal rausspringen.
Guck mal, die machen das richtig.
Die rennen schon weg.
Die rennen auch schon weg.
Brums.
Ich sehe nichts.
Das ist doch kein Video von 2021 bei der Bildqualität.
Das ist ein Video von 85 oder so.
What the fuck?
2021, ja, ja, ist klar.
She baited.
Aus dem Kriech ist das noch hier.
So schlechte Bildqualität ist das.
Oh.
Rums.
Alter, die Aufnahmen sind von sonst wann, Mann.
What the f...
Warum?
Hä?
Der Zug fährt ganz normal?
Ach, da vorne.
Da vorne fahren die zusammen.
Alter.
MonkaS.
Exakt das würde ich wahrscheinlich auch machen, ja.
Mix, mixen wir weg.
Steht da ein Datum?
2012.
Siehste?
Oh, oh, der ist ganz schön schnell.
Bäh, Alter, das natscht.
1997, Alter.
Compilation 2001.
Okay, die Compilation ist von 2021.
Das hier ist doch in fucking schwarz-weiß.
1997, what the fuck?
Wollte ich gerade sagen, das passiert ja anscheinend nicht oft genug, dass man da eine Compilation von machen könnte.
Was haben sie denn hier ausgebuddelt?
Ist das, ist das aus dem wilden Westen?
Oder was?
1700 noch was.
Der macht's richtig.
Der, der, der flüchtet gleich erstmal direkt aus.
Alter, was ein Schwachsinn.
Was ein Schwachsinn, man.
Warum geht, also.
Das ist, das ist so eine typische Compilation, die die Welt nicht braucht.
Der lädt das gleiche Video jedes Jahr in einer anderen Reihenfolge hoch.
Wahrscheinlich, ja.
I made an USB-C iPhone 13.
Warum Schulnoten fast nichts bringen.
Okay.
Lassen wir uns mal wieder ein überdramatisiertes Simplicissimus Video angucken.
Immer wenn der irgendwas erzählt, hört sich das so ultradramatisch und so übertrieben betont immer an.
Wo du immer denkst, wow, jetzt ist aber ganz, ganz schlimm, was passiert.
Gucken wir mal.
Wir haben unfassbar viel Zeit unseres Lebens in der Schule.
Ja.
Und nach dem Abschluss zählt eigentlich nur eins.
Hast du überhaupt gelernt, Alter?
In Deutschland wird das größtenteils in Form von Noten bewertet.
Unsere Noten entscheiden über unser Leben.
Werden wir in die nächste Stufe versetzt?
Welche Ausbildungsplätze kriegen wir?
Dürfen wir studieren?
Dürfen wir studieren, was wir uns wünschen?
Deswegen wollen so viele YouTuber und Streamer werden heutzutage wahrscheinlich.
Das kann jeder machen prinzipiell.
Dabei zeigen etliche Studien, dass man Noten häufig nicht wirklich vertrauen kann.
Einige Experten fordern sogar ihre komplette Abschaffung.
Und ein paar Länder verzichten sogar schon teilweise auf sie.
Sollten wir...
Ich weiß nicht, ob so eine gute Idee ist, komplett auf Noten zu verzichten.
Weiterhin an sehr gut befriedigend, mangelhaft und...
Ich meine, in irgendeiner Art und Weise muss man es ja schon einschätzen können,
ob jemand in dem Bereich irgendwie was auf die Reihe bekommt oder nicht.
... festhalten.
Anders gefragt, brauchen wir Noten überhaupt noch?
Oh, ist das jetzt auf einmal so laut?
Okay.
Okay, bevor wir debattieren, was deine 5- in Kunst über dich als Mensch aussagt,
wollen wir euch kurz unsere Mini-Klamotten...
Ich hab's mal geschafft, in Religion eine 5 zu kriegen.
Kein Spaß.
Religion, Alter.
Oder weiß ich, ob es schon Ethik war?
Ich habe einfach nichts gemacht.
Ich war noch nicht mal anwesend.
Zum größten Teil.
Doch, das stimmt nicht.
Doch, zum größten Teil war ich anwesend.
Ich war manchmal nicht anwesend, aber ich habe nichts gemacht.
Gar nichts.
Ich habe es tatsächlich geschafft, in Religion eine 5 zu kriegen.
Gibt Schlimmeres.
Culture, Culture.
Die gibt es schon seit 2018.
Brauch keine Klamotten von euch.
Wirklich.
Wir haben erfahrene Leute.
Wir haben ganz sch...
Fallenere Sachen.
Jetzt zurück zu deiner 5 in Kunst.
Mit Noten soll die Leistung von Schülern bewertet werden.
Eine einzelne Ziffer ist da simpel und praktisch.
Wer eine 2 in Mathe hat, ist gut in Mathe.
Außerdem ist er besser als jemand,
der nur eine 3 minus hat.
So schaffen Noten Vergleichbarkeit.
Doch nicht nur das.
Tatsächlich gibt es einen relativ engen Zusammenhang
zwischen guten Schulleistungen
und später auch guten Erfolgen im Studium.
Das ist Heinz-Peter Meidinger.
Er war lange Zeit...
Vor allem ist es dann ultraabhängig davon,
was du für einen Lehrer hast.
Das mit Vergleichbarkeit, ja, im Prinzip verstehe ich das schon.
Sollen ja alle ungefähr das gleiche beigebracht kriegen und so.
Aber es ist...
Also ich weiß es bei mir.
Also es konnte das gleiche Fach gewesen sein.
Mit dem einen Lehrer war ich richtig gut,
mit dem anderen war ich richtig scheiße.
Als Deutschlehrer und Schulleiter...
Vor allem lernt man an Noten...
Sieht man an Noten wahrscheinlich,
wie gut jemand auswendig lernen kann.
... und ist seit 5 Jahren Präsident des Deutschen Lehrerverbandes.
Laut ihm können Schulnoten unsere späteren Leistungen
in Studium und Beruf einigermaßen zuverlässig vorhersagen.
Das gilt anscheinend besonders für das Fach Mathe
und ein späteres Studium zum Beispiel in den Naturwissenschaften.
Noten scheinen ihren Zweck insofern irgendwo zu erfüllen.
Warum dann dieses Video mit diesem Titel, fragt ihr euch?
Weil es Geld gibt.
Es gibt nicht nur 2 oder 3 Einwände gegen Noten,
sondern ich könnte hier sozusagen den Gegenpart spielen
und könnte 10 und 20 Argumente gegen Noten bringen,
die alle irgendwie...
irgendwie berechtigt sind.
Was genau eine Note bedeutet, bleibt häufig unklar.
Die 2 in Englisch sagt nichts über die Stärken und Schwächen im jeweiligen Fach aus.
Gutes Textverständnis, aber dafür viele Rechtschreibfehler.
Perfekte Aussprache, aber dafür Hausaufgaben vergessen.
Noten sind immer ein Durchschnittswert.
Man vergisst ja prinzipiell immer Hausaufgaben.
Es ist nicht so, dass man zu faul ist oder keinen Bock hat, den Scheiß zu machen.
Nein, nein, ich hab das auch immer nur vergessen zu machen.
... der sich aus verschiedenen Teilen zusammensetzt.
Ich hab's ja auch manchmal einfach nur vergessen mitzunehmen, ja.
Innerhalb einer Klasse gibt es meist nur ein paar Einsen.
Außerdem nur wenige Fünfen und Sechsen.
Dafür deutlich mehr Zweien, Dreien und Vieren.
Ja gut.
Für alle mit 1+.
Ich mein, das ist eine ziemlich normale Verteilung, würde ich sagen, ja.
So hätte ich das auch erwartet.
Dass es ein paar ganz schlechte gibt und ein paar ganz gute.
Und der Rest ist irgendwie so in der Mitte.
Sternchen in Mathe.
Noten folgen grob einer Normalverteilung.
Ja, genau.
Diese Verteilung bleibt unabhängig davon, wie gut eine Klasse ist, meistens gleich.
Das heißt, in einer Klasse mit nur richtig guten Schülern
gibt es genauso viele Einsen, Zweien, Dreien und so weiter wie in einer schwächeren Klasse.
Ist das so?
Ich kann als Schüler der Klasse 9a eine 2 in Englisch haben.
Weil ich mein, die Klassen werden ja nicht einsortiert nach die sind gut und die sind schlecht.
Im Durchschnitt, im Durchschnitt sind die Klassen alle ungefähr gleich gut.
Du hast vielleicht mal ein paar, wo du nur einen richtigen Five-Hat dabei hast und ein paar, wo du fünf richtige Five-Hats dabei hast.
Aber im Durchschnitt, nachdem die Leute ja nicht nach wie schlau bist du in die Klasse gesteckt werden, sollten die Klassen auch ungefähr gleich gut sein.
In der 9c wäre es bei gleicher Leistung aber eine 4.
Vielen Experten zufolge kann man Noten außerhalb des Klassenzimmers deshalb gar nicht miteinander vergleichen.
Ist das so?
In den Schulen und Bundesländern sowieso nicht.
Auch im Abi ist eine 4 plus in Deutsch in Bayern nicht mit einer 4 plus in Berlin vergleichbar.
Aber wie sieht es denn dann innerhalb des Klassenzimmers aus?
Naja, das kommt ganz auf den Lehrer an.
Lehrer und Lehrerinnen haben zwar ein paar grobe Vorgaben, aber ansonsten ziemlich viel Spielraum bei ihren Schwerpunkten.
Ich glaub das kennt jeder. Gleiches Fach, anderer Lehrer, schlechter oder viel besser, je nachdem.
Das sind Hausaufgaben und die Ergebnisse aus unangekündigten Tests wichtig.
Andere setzen auf mündliche Mitarbeit und Präsentationen.
Und auch bei der Benotung gibt es Unterschiede.
Manche Lehrer und Lehrerinnen bewerten strenger, um ihre Klasse zu fordern.
Andere wollen lieber mit guten Noten motivieren.
Sie können zum Beispiel selbst entscheiden, wie viele Punkte Abzug es für eine falsche Antwort gibt.
Der Lehrer ist der Dreh- und Angelpunkt deiner Noten.
Auch Studien zeigen, dass die Benotung...
Das ist ja auch wichtig, dass du irgendeinen hast, dem das nicht am Arsch vorbeigeht.
Wobei ich halt glaube, umso länger du den Beruf machst, umso mehr wird es dir zwangsläufig am Arsch vorbeigehen.
... der gleichen Arbeit, je nach Lehrkraft, deutlich schwankt.
Das gilt besonders für Fächer wie Deutsch. Bei einer Gedichtanalyse...
Wie, Abzug für falsche Antwort? Ja, warum einfach gar nichts hinschreiben? Easy win.
... kann man immer darüber streiten, ob der Vers eine Metapher ist oder nicht.
Aber auch vermeintlich objektivere Fächer wie Mathe werden je nach Lehrer unterschiedlich bewertet.
Aber nicht nur das.
Selbst die Stimmung einer Lehrkraft wirkt sich auf unsere Note aus.
Ist sie gut gelaunt, wenn sie meine Arbeit korrigiert? Hoffentlich schon.
Ist sie vielleicht schon voreingenommen, wenn sie die Klassenarbeit in die Hand nimmt?
Ja, da ist tatsächlich viel Varianz drin. Logisch.
Finn kriegt immer eine Eins in Musik und ist allgemein ein absoluter Vorzeigeschüler.
Sein Aufsatz wird also vielleicht intuitiv besser bewertet als der eines bekanntlich schlechteren Schülers.
Dieses Phänomen nennt man Beharrlichkeitstendenz.
Die Reihenfolge im Stapel spielt ebenfalls eine Rolle.
Wird mein Aufsatz später korrigiert, wird er oft besser bewertet.
Also an der Berufsschule hatten wir auch einen Lehrer, der war das letzte Jahr da und danach geht er in Rente.
Ihr könnt euch vorstellen, wie hochmotiviert er war.
... gute Arbeit und meine ist eher nicht so gut. Ihr könnt es euch denken.
Es kommt auch vor, dass die Lehrkraft milder bewertet.
Wenn ein Schüler oder eine Schülerin durch die schlechte Note beispielsweise eine gute Arbeit macht, dann ist das eine gute Arbeit.
Wenn ein Schüler oder eine Schülerin durch die schlechte Note beispielsweise sitzen bleiben würde.
Ach ja, Mädchen bekommen bei gleicher Leistung tendenziell bessere Noten.
Anzeige ist raus.
Mein Geschlecht, wie gut meine Klassenkameraden sind, die Stimmung meines Lehrers sowie seine Anforderungen,
all diese Faktoren beeinflussen die eigene Note und häufig auch die eigene Zukunft.
Noten haben eine subjektive Komponente.
Es ist immer unser Bestreben als Lehrerverband gewesen,
in der Lehrerausbildung und generell auch starken Wert darauf zu legen,
dass Lehrkräfte sich ihrer Subjektivität bewusst werden.
Das sind so Dinge, dessen muss man sich bewusst machen.
Diese Effekte gibt es, die kann man nie ganz ausmerzen.
Es gleicht sich natürlich insgesamt einigermaßen aus.
Das ist ja der Punkt.
Warum dann doch ein Zusammenhang zwischen Noten und Spielen?
Aber reicht es aus, wenn sich Ungerechtigkeiten am Ende insgesamt einigermaßen ausgleichen?
Unfaire Noten treffen häufig besonders sozial schwache Schüler.
Klar, eine gute Leistung überzeugt.
Trotzdem spielt die soziale Herkunft eine sehr große Rolle bei dem schulischen Erfolg und den Noten eines Kindes.
Ob Lehrer wirklich Leute schlechter bewerten?
Weil sie aus ärmeren Verhältnissen kommen?
Also, das würde mich jetzt mal interessieren, wie man da drauf kommt.
Also, da würde ich eher sagen, das dürfte dem Lehrer ziemlich wurscht sein.
Ich meine, gut, du hast vielleicht, wenn du aus ärmeren Verhältnissen kommst
oder irgendwie Migrationshintergrund hast oder sonst was,
du hast Sprachprobleme, du hast vielleicht irgendwelche Bildungslücken noch aus der Vergangenheit oder so.
Ansonsten, wenn da halt was ordentliches ist, dann ist das auch gut.
Wenn man halt was ordentliches schreibt.
Auf der anderen Seite kannst du jetzt ja auch nicht sagen,
nur weil jemand nicht viel Geld hat,
kannst du ja nicht für die gleiche Leistung auf einmal bessere Noten geben.
Wäre ja genauso bescheuert.
Keine Ahnung.
Und das schon in der Grundschule.
Verschiedene Studien zeigen, dass Kinder aus sozial schwächeren Familien
beim Übergang in die weiterführende Schule über schlechtere Voraussetzungen verfügen
und dadurch auch schlechtere Noten schreiben.
Bei gleicher Leistung schlechtere Noten bekommen.
Ich meine, wenn du nicht richtig reden kannst,
wenn du von der vierten Klasse in die fünfte Klasse kommst
und du kannst nicht richtig lesen und schreiben und nicht richtig reden,
dann ist das natürlich ein Problem.
Aber wie willst du das dann in Noten,
also du kannst dem ja dann nicht die gleiche Note geben wie einem, der das kann.
Kommt natürlich aufs Fach an.
Es gibt bestimmte Fächer, wo das keine Rolle spielt.
Das würde mich jetzt mal interessieren, was das genau ist.
Und seltener eine Gymnasial-Empfehlung erhalten.
Dabei kann schon der eigene Name oder der Bezirk, in dem man lebt,
zu einer schlechteren Beurteilung führen.
In der weiterführenden Schule nimmt die soziale Ungleichheit dann sogar zu.
Von 100 Kindern ohne Akademikereltern beginnen nur 21 ein Studium.
Acht von ihnen machen einen Master und nur eins...
Ja, das liegt wahrscheinlich aber auch daran,
wenn ihr jetzt mal Bezug nehmt auf, ähm,
äh, da meinen Arbeitsalltag.
Das sind dann aber auch welche, die haben ganz andere Ziele.
Da hast du dann zum Beispiel Mädels drinne,
die der Meinung sind, mit 17, äh, 17, 18, 19 erstmal zwei Kinder droppen und ausgesorgt haben.
Ja, da musst du dich nicht wundern, dass sie nicht studieren gehen wollen.
Die wollen ja nicht.
Das liegt nicht daran, dass irgendwie man ihnen die Zukunft verbauen will und sie wollte nicht.
21 ein Studium.
Acht von ihnen machen einen Master und nur eins erwirbt einen Doktortitel.
Schaut euch zu all dem gerne auch unsere anderen Videos zum deutschen Schulsystem an.
Ein weiteres Problem von Noten haben wir noch gar nicht angesprochen.
Rund 30 Prozent aller Schüler und Schülerinnen in Deutschland berichten von Ängsten und hartem Leistungsdruck.
Laut einer Umfrage des Forsa-Instituts aus dem Jahr 2020 verstärke sich dieses Stressempfinden besonders bei der Zeugnisvergabe.
Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Viele Schüler haben regelrecht Panik vor dem Zeugnis.
Dabei sind sie vor allem...
Ich hatte nie Panik vor dem Zeugnis, weil ich eigentlich schon immer vorher wusste, was ich für Noten bekomme.
Ich hatte eher Panik davor, wenn ich wusste, dass ich die Arbeit, wenn ich irgendeine Arbeit schlecht geschrieben habe, dass es sie zurückgibt.
... hoher Ansprüche gestresst. Selten ist eine Note noch gut genug. Eine 3 ist nicht mehr befriedigend. Man strebt nach einer 2 oder sogar nach einer 1.
Das war bei mir auch schon so.
Ganz ehrlich, natürlich wolltest du lieber eine 1 oder eine 2 haben, weil sehr gut und gut nur einfach besser ist als eine 3 oder eine 4.
Natürlich wolltest du das haben.
Es war nicht wirklich schlimm, wenn du eine 3 hattest oder so, aber du wolltest schon eher eine 1 oder eine 2 haben.
Wobei halt dann halt dort auch, weil inzwischen gerne wollen und kriegen ist halt ein Unterschied.
Also ich hatte keine...
Also ich hatte keine guten Noten, kann ich gleich sagen. Also in der normalen Schule hatte ich keine so nicht guten Noten.
Ja, ich habe es irgendwie geschafft, aber wirklich super Zeugnisse hatte ich nicht.
Ein paar Fächer war ich wirklich gut.
Physik beispielsweise hatte ich immer gute Noten.
Mathe hat geschwankt, je nach Lehrer. War richtig gut, war eher schlecht.
Informatik, IT hatte ich immer eine 1.
Wobei, das war bei uns, hatte nichts mit Informatik, IT zu tun.
Damals, das waren eher, wie erstelle ich Wordvorlagen und so Blödsinn.
Ähm, ansonsten weiß ich es gar nicht mehr so genau.
Ja, Musik war auch nicht so... Doch, Musik war glaube ich ganz okay.
Deutsch war ich ganz gut.
Ahnung, ist schon so lange her.
Wenn man die Frage stellt, wie kommen Kinder mit Noten klar, dann glaube ich ist noch fast...
Ist das ganz stark auch davon abhängig.
Wie kommen Eltern mit Noten klar?
Laut Meidinger und vielen weiteren...
Da hat er recht, da hat er recht. Na klar.
Dir wäre die Note scheißegal, wenn du keinen Anschiss danach bekommst.
So ist es. Da hat er schon recht.
Ja, wenn du eine 5 schreibst und weißt, es interessiert keinen, dann ist dir das auch egal.
Auf der anderen Seite ist halt, was für ein Anreiz hast du, das besser zu machen, wenn es keinen interessiert.
Experten sollten Eltern unbedingt entspannter werden, was Noten angeht.
Und auch mal schlechter.
Ich würde auch mal schlechtere Noten loben.
Ganz im Ernst, was ich noch aus meiner Zeit so mitgenommen habe ist, Eltern überschätzen das unglaublich, wie wichtig irgendwelche Noten sind in der, keine Ahnung, 6. Klasse oder so.
Die denken so nach dem Motto, du hast eine 5 in irgendeinem Fach und boah, da wird ja nie was aus dem.
Das ist natürlich Schwachsinn.
Wenn du in der 5. oder 6. Klasse irgendwie eine 5 in irgendeinem Fach...
Es ist scheißegal.
Es interessiert absolut keine Sau.
Ist so.
Juckt kein Mensch später mehr.
Und es wird zwar immer gesagt, ja, das baut alles aufeinander auf, ist es aber gar nicht.
Die meisten Fächer bauen nicht in dieser Art und Weise aufeinander auf.
Also wenn du die Basics, wenn du die Basics kannst und dann was weiß ich, wenn du in Physik, wenn du in Physik verkackt hast bei Thema A.
Und ein Jahr später kommt Thema B, dann ist es nicht unbedingt so, dass du Thema A zwingend brauchst.
Ja, es baut schon einiges aufeinander auf, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass wenn man einmal verkackt hat, man für immer weiter verkackt, so nach dem Motto.
... uns zwar zum Lernen motivieren, gleichzeitig sind sie häufig aber sehr demotivierend für schwächere Schüler.
Ist es also an der Zeit...
Naja.
Gut.
Ich meine, wenn du Noten vergibst, dann ist das halt eines der Dinger.
Klar.
Klar, wenn du schlechte Noten kriegst, ist es demotivierend, okay, aber das ist halt...
Dann müsstest du höchstens sagen, gut, dann lässt man es gleich bleiben.
Weil in irgendeiner Art und Weise, sobald du Vergleiche hast, musst du halt damit klarkommen, dass die, die halt schlechte abschneiden in diesem Vergleich, halt das nicht so geil finden.
Dann müsstest du es weglassen.
Noten einfach mal abzuschaffen.
Erinnert ihr euch noch an die Texte auf den ersten Grundschulzeugnissen?
Das waren Wortzeugnisse mit verbalen Beurteilungen.
Weiß ich nicht mehr.
Solche Beurteilungen können in Deutschland bis zur achten Klasse eine Alternative sein.
Wortzeugnisse ermöglichen einen differenzierten, konstruktiven Blick auf den persönlichen Lernfortschritt eines Schülers oder einer Schülerin.
Unsinnige, stressige Notenvergleiche untereinander fallen weg.
Vor allem leistungsschwächere Schüler scheinen von Schulen ohne Noten zu profitieren und dann später bessere Leistungen zu erzielen.
In Hessen dürfen einige Schulen die klassischen Zeugnisse schon durch Wortzeugnisse erzielen.
Die Regelung ist zwar für alle Schulformen offen, wird aktuell aber hauptsächlich von Grund- und Gesamtschulen genutzt.
Wenn Schüler von solchen Schulen wechseln oder sie verlassen wollen, müssen sie allerdings auch Zeugnisse mit klassischen Noten erhalten.
Deutsche Waldorfschulen und sogenannte reformpädagogische Modellschulen verzichten bis zur Oberstufe auf Noten.
In Finnland gibt es bis zur neunten Klasse keine Noten.
In Schweden bis zur sechsten Klasse.
Beide Länder schneiden bei der größten Schule...
Das klingt doch sinnvoll, oder?
Das deckt sich doch auch mit dem, was ich vorhin gesagt habe.
Die Noten in den unteren Klassen jucken, da geht eh kein Hahn mehr danach.
...Listungsstudie PISA größtenteils gleich oder besser als Deutschland ab.
Wortzeugnisse sind allerdings sehr aufwendig.
Das ist nicht gerade günstig, wenn es ohnehin schon viel zu wenige Lehrkräfte gibt.
Das ist, glaube ich, auch eines der großen Probleme, die wir haben.
Ja, das ist schlicht und ergreifend.
In vielen dieser Bereichen.
Guckt euch mal an.
Nicht nur in der Schule.
Ja?
Ich muss jetzt ja gar nicht bis ins Altenheim oder Krankenhaus gucken.
Es gibt zu wenig Leute in diesen Bereichen.
...bewertungsprobleme in der Schule.
Und die sind eh schon...
Ich möchte nicht Lehrer sein.
Ganz ehrlich, Lehrer wäre so eines der grausamsten Berufe.
Das könnte mir kein...
Für kein Geld der Welt würde ich mich da hinsetzen.
Bei einer irgendwie siebten, achten, neunten Klasse, Alter.
Im Leben nicht.
Meine Kinder sind schon abfucknervig.
Menschen an sich sind abfucknervig.
Aber Jugendliche ist, glaube ich, das Nervigste, was es auf der Welt gibt.
Wenn man dann sagt, okay, wir setzen anstelle von Noten Verbalurteile oder Portfolios oder wie auch immer.
Gibt es ja bestimmte Möglichkeiten.
Ich bin dafür, die Noten durch Twitch-Emotes zu ersetzen.
Das geht dann von kekwait zu kekw.
Zu Postchamp, zu Fivehead.
Also ich bin dafür, das alles durch Twitch-Emotes zu ersetzen.
In Kunst kannst du dann beispielsweise...
...als Note bekommen.
In Sport bekommst du ein Gatschi-Roll.
Das fände ich nicht schlecht.
Einfach Twitch-Emotes-Bewertung.
Dann steckt natürlich dieser subjektive Faktor genauso drin.
Bei der Lehrkraft.
Solange Menschen involviert bleiben, können Bewertungen laut Meidingern
niemals zu 100% objektiv sein.
Egal welche Form gewählt wird.
Deshalb sei es wichtig, dass Lehrkräfte sich ihrer Subjektivität bewusst werden
und damit professionell und gerecht umgehen.
Noten haben einen extrem hohen Stellenwert in unserem Schulsystem.
Sie sind wahnsinnig wichtig für Eltern und Schüler.
Oft lösen sie Stress und teilt sogar Panik aus.
Nicht zuletzt entscheiden sie über die eigene berufliche und akademische Zukunft.
Sie repräsentieren das angebliche eigene Wissen.
Die angeblichen eigenen Fähigkeiten.
Für einige den angeblichen eigenen Wert.
Die etlichen Schwächen dieses sechsstufigen Systems werden dabei häufig vergessen.
Eine 2 in Englisch kann viel bedeuten.
Vielleicht gibt sie sogar einen grob richtigen Gesamteindruck.
Also das, wie das Schweden und Finnland macht, finde ich eigentlich sinnvoll.
Dass man erst Noten später gibt.
Weil die Noten 6. oder 7. Klasse oder so jucken eh keinen.
Wobei die Noten dann sagen wir mal je nachdem.
9. 10. oder 11. 12. Je nachdem wann du fertig bist.
Klasse schon eher.
Aber weder vergleichbar noch gerecht.
Vielleicht halten wir zu verbissen an unserem Notensystem fest.
Weil es einfach, praktisch und vertraut ist.
Bei alternativen Beurteilungen fragen Eltern und Schüler oft am Ende trotzdem.
Und was wäre das für eine Note?
Dieses System komplett aufzugeben wird wahrscheinlich schwierig.
Wir könnten aber ernsthaft darüber diskutieren, Noten beispielsweise erst ab der 8. Klasse einzuführen.
Vielleicht könnten die Schüler von morgen damit ein klein bisschen weniger Leistungsdruck aufwachsen.
Cheers.
Die Frage ist halt, das würde mich aber interessieren.
Wenn du gar keinen Druck mehr hast, das zu lernen, lernst du es dann?
Auf der anderen Seite, vielleicht lernst du dann das, worauf du Bock hast.
Was dir im Endeffekt auch was bringt.
Hey.
Kann man wahrscheinlich lang drüber diskutieren.
Weil vieles, was man in der Schule lernt, ist halt komplett umsonst.
Gerade wenn ich überlege, dass du in Chemie irgendwelche Massen berechnet hast und sowas.
Ja, nice, aber nee.
Warum muss jemand sitzen? Ja, das verstehe ich auch nicht.
Es ist die Frage, ob das überhaupt so ist.
Das ist ja auch so. Das scheint ja auch, je nachdem, unterschiedliche Regelungen pro Schule zu geben.
Wenn ich jetzt innerhalb der nächsten Tage eine Web...
App-Webseite basierend auf meinen C-Sharp-Kenntnissen entwickeln möchte,
weil ich so in welcher Stelle...
Wie viele Kenntnisse hast du denn?
Weil, wenn du jetzt noch Tutorials brauchst...
Also...
Wie gut kannst du denn schon was?
Also, wenn du eine Webseite entwickeln willst...
Also eine Webseite, du willst ja eine Web-Anwendung entwickeln.
Also, du kommst an CSS, JavaScript, HTML eigentlich nicht vorbei.
Ach so, ja. Gut.
Also, dann würde ich mir backend-technisch keine Probleme sehen.
Hm.
Dann ist halt die Frage...
Wie...
Ja, wie datenzentriert oder nicht das Ganze ist, wenn das einfach nur ein Web-Interface ist,
für irgendwelche Daten, die in der Datenbank stehen.
Dann kannst du das theoretisch komplett in .NET machen mit irgendwie Razor-Pages oder so.
Wobei ich Razor-Pages mega abartig finde.
Aber im Endeffekt kommt man an HTML und JavaScript und CSS eigentlich nicht vorbei.
Also ich würde wahrscheinlich...
Wenn ich jetzt was Neues mache...
Ich würde Vue.js finden.
Ich würde Vue.js fürs Frontend nehmen und irgendeine Minimal-API in ASP.NET Core machen.
Oder aber direkt, wenn es viele Daten zum Abfragen gibt, direkt GraphQL im Backend und dann damit abfragen.
Und dann ist halt ganz entscheidend davon abhängig, was es für eine Anwendung werden soll.
Ja, ist es irgendwie was Interaktives?
Ist es irgendwas mit Karten?
Ist es irgendwas, wo laufend was aktualisiert wird?
Ist es eher irgendwas relativ Statisches?
Das muss man dann halt gucken.
Ja, ich persönlich würde es jetzt mit SvelteKit machen, weil ich in letzter Zeit viel damit gemacht habe.
Aber für jemanden, der es noch nicht gemacht hat, finde ich Vue.js zum Einstieg besser.
Naja, du bekommst ja vorher trotzdem gesagt, ob du gut oder schlecht bist.
Ist halt nur die Frage, ob das in Noten sein muss.
Wenn du eine öffentliche Web-Anwendung machst, wo du willst, dass Suchmaschinen die ordentlich indizieren können, dann ist es wieder was anderes.
Dann ist Server-Side-Rendering zumindest initial besser.
Weil dann hat die Suchmaschine was zum Indizieren.
Also es hängt ganz entscheidend davon ab, was es für eine Anwendung sein soll.
Wenn du sogar Mobile supporten willst, dass du vielleicht irgendwann mal eine App draus machst oder zumindest eine PWA, dann sieht das wieder ganz anders aus.
Also es ist Preisfrage eigentlich, was man genau machen will.
Es gibt mittlerweile 5.000 Möglichkeiten, Web-Anwendungen zu bauen.
Das ist doch das, was ich gesagt habe.
Du meinst das doch hier oben.
Es ist blöd, wenn du die ganze Zeit keine Noten kriegst und man dann erst später gesagt bekommt, ob das jetzt gut oder schlecht ist.
Und dann hast du keine Chance mehr, das zu verbessern.
Du bekommst ja schon gesagt, ob das gut oder schlecht ist.
Du kriegst aber halt nicht gesagt, du hast eine 1, du hast eine 2, du hast eine 6.
Du kriegst gesagt, was weiß ich, Tallerik ist in Mathe, beherrscht den Zahlenraum von 1 bis 100.
Hat noch Verbesserungspotenzial im Bereich XY.
Versus du hast eine 5.
Ja.
Also ich finde, das ist schon was anderes, als einfach nur eine Note hinzuschreiben.
1 bis 100 muss reichen.
So.
Was haben wir ansonsten noch, was können wir ansonsten noch angucken?
Leute, ich muss gleich mal aufs Klo.
Sanitär, Heizung und Klimatechnik.
Was verdient ein Anlagenmechaniker-Meister?
Ich hoffe genug.
Also Leute, brauchen wir.
Death of a Game, New World.
Oh, das gucken wir uns an, aber nicht jetzt.
28 Minuten ist mir zu lang.
7 Essential Command-Line-Tools.
Ok.
9 Minuten.
Das passt jetzt.
Also 7 Essential...
Wir könnten uns einfach...
Wir könnten den Typ G-Baiten...
Ok.
Wir gucken uns das...
Leute, wir machen jetzt Five Head Time.
Wir gucken uns das Video nicht an.
Wir gucken einfach, was es für Command-Line-Tools sind anhand der Chapter.
Five Head.
So.
Exa kenne ich.
Exa ist ein LS-Ersatz.
Der ist tatsächlich ganz gut.
Den verwende ich auch.
Ja.
Also, genau.
Wenn ich LS mache, kommt auch sowas.
Das ist nicht wirklich LS.
Das ist quasi ein LS-Drop-In.
The Fuck mag ich nicht.
Als verstehe ich den Sinn von nicht.
Bat.
Weiß ich nicht, was es macht.
Was macht Bat?
GitHub.
Bat.
Cat-Clone.
Super.
Das hat die Welt gebraucht.
Bat-Chest.
Dieses Emote war ja mal eine Zeit lang.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das macht.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Dieses Emote war ja mal eine Zeit lang omnipräsent auf Twitch.
Mittlerweile nicht mehr.
Rip-Grab.
Okay, schnelleres Grab, ja kann man verwenden.
Gibt es zig Alternativen zu.
Ich persönlich mag ja das Standard-Grab, einfach weil es überall dabei ist.
FZF, das ist tatsächlich ganz cool.
Da kannst du so Dropdown-Menüs mit generieren, Selection-Menüs.
Zoxxide, kenne ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Ah, das ist irgendein...
Wir jumpen in verschiedene...
Das ist quasi Bookmark fürs Terminal.
Okay.
Ent-Entre.
Entre kenne ich auch nicht.
Entre.
Ach so.
Ah, das ist im Prinzip das Gleiche wie Ruby...
Ähm...
Ah, wie heißt das Ruby-Automatisch-Reload-Ding?
Hab ich vergessen.
Da gab's mal ein cooles Ruby-Tool,
was genau das Gleiche gemacht hat.
Aber ich hab vergessen, wie es hieß.
Ewig nicht mehr verwendet.
Es ist nicht...
Es ist nicht Enter, es hieß...
Oh, wie hieß das denn?
Ich hatte vor Jahren schon so ein
Ruby-Tool.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch.
Mit C oder so am Anfang vielleicht?
Weiß ich nicht.
Midnight Commander.
Ne.
Nein.
Mag ich überhaupt nicht.
Ich versteh den Sinn davon nicht.
Leute, ich hab keine Ahnung, warum man sowas braucht.
Wirklich nicht.
Also, ich kenne auch...
Bei mir auf der Arbeit gibt's einige, die schwören auf sowas in der Richtung.
Ja, oder Raid?
Ich versteh den...
Ich versteh den Sinn davon nicht.
Wenn ich was moven will,
dann mach ich das mit MV über die Kommandozeile genauso schnell,
wie hier...
Also, ich verstehe ernsthaft den Sinn von den Pfeilen...
Von diesen, äh, Kommandozeilen-Pfeilen...
Oder auch von grafischen Pfeilmanagern nicht.
Ich kopier den Kram über die Kommandozeile,
ich move den Kram über die Kommandozeile,
ich editier den Kram über die Kommandozeile.
Wozu brauch ich so einen Manager?
Oder auch Ranger oder so.
Ich versteh...
Den Sinn versteh ich nicht.
Ist Geschmackssache?
Geschmackssache, ja.
Aber ich versteh den...
Ja-Seinsberechtigung nicht so ganz.
SCP machst du falsch rum.
SCB ist immer Quelle-Ziel.
Genauso wie CP.
Das ist ein Pfeilmanager, ja.
Aber LS im Verzeichnis macht ja die gleiche Übersicht.
Oder Entry oder so.
Also, ich glaube, das ist wirklich große Geschmackssache.
LN, LN, LN ist auch Quelle-Ziel.
LN ist von wo du verlinken willst, wohin du verlinken willst.
Also, dort wo der...
LN ist das, was du verlinkst als erstes, und dann, wo der Link erscheint.
Aber gut, ich versteh's.
Aber das weiß ich nicht, ob dir das hilft beim LN.
EXA ist der LS-Ersatz.
Der ist wirklich ganz nice.
Den verwende ich auch.
Guckt hier.
Das habt ihr auch schon öfters gesehen.
Wahrscheinlich wusstet ihr nicht, dass es EXA ist,
sondern habt gedacht, das ist LS.
Die Sync ist meistens vornach, ja.
Außer bei AirSync, da ist es im Prinzip auch so.
Aber AirSync hat so viele tausende Kommandos,
dass da kommt man manchmal ein bisschen durcheinander.
Das ist bei mir auch EXA hier.
Ich hab das einfach gealiasst auf LS.
So.
Okay.
Haben wir das Video im Schnelldurchgang durch?
Oh ja.
Wichtig.
Während wir gucken, was wir als nächstes schauen.
Sekunde.
Hell yeah.
Almost heaven.
Was ist das denn?
What the fuck?
OKS.
Alter, das sieht ja richtig gut aus.
Alter, mega.
Das sieht ja mal richtig gut aus.
Warum hat der, hat der, äh, so Dinger im Auge?
Ach so, jetzt verstehe ich's.
Das soll das Spiegel simulieren.
Okay, das ist, das ist mal richtig Highskill.
Dance Game.
Bratwurst-Timelapse.
Alter.
Wonka.
Dance Game.
Verschimmelte und ver-ver-ver-ver-Vermaden aufgefräste Bratwürste.
Kappa Pock Jam.
Biblethumb.
Windows Defender now available on all platforms.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir uns das angucken müssen.
Das sagt wahrscheinlich 30 Sekunden, was sinnvoll ist, danach ist Blabla.
Was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an?
Leute, ich glaube, wir gucken uns nichts mehr an.
Ich muss so dringend aufs Klo.
Ich glaube, wir werden das folgendermaßen machen.
Ich gehe jetzt gleich auf, dann gehe ich aufs Klo, dann esse ich was.
Und dann machen wir noch ein bisschen, äh, Bastelkram heute wieder.
Twitchy-Modes.
Erkriege.
Na dann.
Twitchy-Modes.
Was bastelt?
Ich weiß doch nicht genau.
Ne, Leute.
Das wird erstmal doch nichts.
Ähm, ich muss ja Video hochladen.
Aber danach vielleicht.
Ich muss ja noch Video hochladen.
Wobei das ja schon fertig ist.
Das ist Best-of.
Best-of-Zusammenschnitt.
Aber guckt euch das mal an und sagt mir, wie ihr es findet.
Heute Mittag.
Vielleicht, wenn ihr es im Stream gesehen habt.
Weil es ist wirklich massiv.
Aber finde ich gut zusammengecuttet.
Von 45 Minuten Max Gelaber auf 9 Minuten.
Echt pogge.
Alles klar, Leute.
Wir sehen uns.
Vielleicht nachher.
Bis dann.
Macht's gut.
See you.